Ja Leute, ich war die Woche nicht on, aus zwei Gründen.
Erstens will ich nächstes Wochenende das erste Mal 20 Kilometer am Stück rennen und
ich musste ein bisschen trainen, dass das funktioniert.
Also nicht nur am Stück, sondern auch in einer ordentlichen Zeit am Stück.
Deshalb habe ich mal einen Probelauf gemacht, knapp 14 Kilometer mit knapp 6 Minuten 30
pro Kilometer.
Also mein Ziel ist 20 Kilometer mit 7 Minuten pro Kilometer zu rennen und das sieht gut
aus.
Das sind im Prinzip nur 7 Kilometer mehr, dafür eine halbe Minute pro Kilometer langsamer.
Also soll ich packen.
So, das ist das erste und das zweite ist, warum ich nicht on war, ich bin etwas versackt
in einem ESP32 Progress Projekt, was ich eigentlich ohne Probleme hätte auch on stream machen
können, aber ich kann mich manchmal einfach off stream besser konzentrieren.
Und das das Blöde an dem Projekt ist, das ist nice, aber es ist unsinnig, also ich brauch's
nicht.
Ich mach's einfach nur, weil's geht.
So.
Aber wir basteln ein bisschen zusammen im streamen.
ASD Flex.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Progg.
So, ich muss gerade nochmal mein Trostbrot fertig futtern hier.
Warum hast du dein Board gelöscht, die letzten?
Weil ich irgendwas, ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau was, weil ich irgendwas geleakt habe,
was ich leaken wollte.
Ich kann dir aber gar nicht mehr so genau sagen was.
Wo dabei war's.
Dann gehen wir doch mal.
In meiner Arch, by the way.
Linux VM.
Womit sind das überhaupt noch an?
Kann aus.
Package Updates.
Weil sicherlich 500 Package Updates in der Zwischenzeit reingekommen sind.
Weil Arch Linux so High IQ Pleading Edge ist, dass du fünf mal am Tag aktualisieren kannst,
wenn du willst.
Man muss aber echt den Arch Linux Leuten mal zugute halten.
Weil, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das schon gehört habt.
Ich weiß nicht.
Es gab mal ein Problem mit Grub, das weiß ich noch, vor ungefähr 2 Jahren gab es mal eine Grub-Version.
Aber ansonsten, also, für das wie aktuell und ohne großartige Zusatz-Stage und Tests funktioniert das wirklich erstaunlich gut, kann man nicht sagen.
Also, es wird einfach immer auf das Aktuellste updatet und zu 99% funktioniert das ohne Probleme.
Ah ja, okay. Ja, gut, das kann ich nachvollziehen, wenn sich da irgendwas Grundlegendes geändert hat.
Ja, Updates mit KDE und so stelle ich mir tatsächlich auch ein bisschen schwieriger vor.
Da ändert sich ja öfters mal was. Ja, gerade wenn du KDE von 5 auf 6 oder so upgradest, da haben ja einige Leute Probleme.
Oder bestimmt auch bei der anderen Version, bei Gnome ist es bestimmt ähnlich.
Ich habe das Problem nicht, weil ich verwende einfach kein KDE.
Ich verwende mein Udemy.
Uralt i3 mit, wobei, das ist ja nicht, dass das uralt wäre, also das wird ja immer noch aktualisiert, glaube ich zumindest.
Ist i3 noch maintained? Also, maintained ist es auf jeden Fall noch, aber frage, wie oft da was ankommt.
Jetzt kommt, zeig mal her.
Ja, guck mal hier, bam, bam, bam.
Guck mal hier.
Wir hatten immerhin, hatten die 20, 30 Comments in dieses Jahr schon.
Mehr als der Fiat Champ.
Fuck.
Drei Milliarden, danke schön.
Nö, der Igel.
Mein Problem mit Wayland ist ja in der VM, dass Wayland in der VM nicht richtig funktioniert.
Zumindest nicht ohne irgendwelche Magic Config, hinter die ich noch nicht dahinter gekommen bin, wie sie funktioniert, ja.
Also, ich probiere immer mal wieder Wayland aus, es wird, glaube ich, mal wieder Zeit, eine Runde Wayland auszuprobieren.
Wayland gibt es ja auch schon irgendwie gefühlt seit 15 Jahren und es funktioniert einfach nicht richtig.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass X richtig funktioniert, ja.
X hat sicherlich auch so seine Probleme, aber zumindest in meiner VM funktioniert X deutlich problemloser als Wayland.
X hat auch so seine Probleme, ja.
Zum Beispiel, was seit einem der letzten Updates nicht mehr funktioniert ist, ich zeige euch das mal kurz, ich reboot die jetzt.
Das ist so ein Zwischending zwischen X und VM-Ware und sonst was, da schieben sie sich wahrscheinlich wieder gegenseitig die Schuld zu, wer jetzt daran schuld ist zumindest.
Wenn ich das jetzt nicht Fullscreen habe, früher konnte es mal Resizen, mittlerweile kann das nicht mehr Resizen.
Guckt, hups, mittlerweile kann das nicht mehr Resizen, seht ihr?
Also, das Resize einfach den Desktop nicht mehr, beziehungsweise die Resolution.
Aber ein bisschen Resize tut es noch, man sieht hier nämlich, dass die Leiste schon ein bisschen Resized wird, es checkt bloß die Auflösung nicht richtig, keine Ahnung.
Und wenn man hier guckt, X-Rande.
Kommt auch sowas ganz scheppes bei raus.
Und die eigentliche Auflösung 1920x1080 ist da und die, keine Ahnung.
Oder?
Es switcht nicht mehr automatisch.
Das ist aber nicht so schlimm, weil ich meine, im Endeffekt kannst du das Ding einfach im Fullscreen rebooten.
Ich habe noch nicht rausgekriegt, was ich restarten muss, dass das funktioniert.
Dass ich das vielleicht ohne kompletten Reboot fixt.
Aber wenn ich das so mache, wenn ich das im Fullscreen starte, dann ist es gar kein Problem.
Dann ist es Fullscreen.
Aber, witzigerweise, stayt es jetzt auch im Fullscreen und wird nicht mehr klein.
Was auch immer, der Fehler tritt auf, seitdem ich den von VMware, beziehungsweise Prodcom contributeden Open Source VMware Treiber verwende für die GPU.
Anstelle den Proprietären von VMware, den ich früher, also keine Ahnung, Schwachsinn, stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Anstatt das Zusatzpaket und jetzt verwende ich den im Kernel, seitdem funktioniert das Resize nicht mehr.
Warum?
Weiß man nicht.
Was?
Okay, da fehlt der zweite Satz, zweite Satzhälfte.
Ja.
Und es wird mal eigentlich wieder Zeit, Wayland auszuprobieren.
Also, wie gesagt, das sind so Probleme, die ich mit X in der VM habe.
Also, da ist auch nicht alles perfekt.
Aber, Wayland funktioniert bei mir in der VM einfach gar nicht richtig.
Zum Beispiel, refresht mein Screen in der VM nicht, wenn ich Wayland starte.
Keine Ahnung, Sway starten.
Mit Wayland.
Und der Screen refresht nicht.
Man muss dann irgendeine Environment, also, ich meine, es ist relativ obvious, dass man eine grafische Oberfläche nicht benutzen kann mit 0 FPS.
Weil es passiert einfach nichts.
Da kann man irgendeine Environment-Variable setzen, dann geht es aber auch nicht gut.
Und, also, ich habe mit Wayland so viele Probleme gehabt in der VM.
Natürlich kann man jetzt sagen, ja, liegt an VMware, liegt an Wayland, liegt an Linux, whatever.
Ich sage euch ganz ehrlich, es ist mir scheißegal, an wem es liegt.
Ich würde es benutzen, wenn es funktioniert.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was die Distros mit, sagen wir mal, KDE oder Gnome im Default und Default Wayland anders machen, weil die funktionieren ganz brauchbar in der VM.
Aber, wenn ich das selbst installiere und beispielsweise was wie Sway benutze als i3-Ersatz, nö, nix, kein Bock.
Ja, mag Wayland nicht.
Was wäre für dich ein Replacement für eine 1060 an einem Coop-Aktiv...
Oh, da kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Das Ding ist, ich kenne mich genau aus mit PC-Hardware, wenn ich mir einen neuen PC kaufen will.
Dann lese ich mir 1-2 Wochen aktuelle Builds, Entwicklungen und sonst was durch, kaufe mir einen Rechner.
Und dann habe ich für 2-5 Jahre wieder keine Ahnung von aktueller Desktop-Hardware.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Chat nur für verifizierte Konten, Kequade.
Wollen die mir etwas sagen?
Eine Fake-E-Mail, mit der ich mir den zweiten Account hier gemacht habe, nicht legit ist.
Ja klar, aber das wissen wir ja.
Ja, dass man nicht einfach immer das Schnellste reinpappen soll und das dann halt auch teuer ist, ist ja klar.
Also, mein Monitor-Setup ist noch ziemlich easy.
Ich habe zwei Rechner hier stehen, meinen aktuellen, meinen alten, einen Monitor an dem und einen Monitor an dem anderen.
Hier habe ich einen schnellen 240 Hertz BenQ-Monitor dran für Hackerman-Gaming-Kram.
Und am anderen Rechner habe ich einen alten ISO-Monitor dran.
Den habe ich ja schon lange dran, aber der ist kalibriert.
Wenn ich mal irgendwas mir angucken will, so farbecht und wie man es drucken könnte und so, dann mache ich das auf dem linken Bildschirm.
Ansonsten hier, das andere Teil hier ist halt so eingestellt, dass es für das tägliche Angucken mir am angenehmsten ist.
Was nicht unbedingt...
Exaktheit in den Farben heißt, ja.
Ich glaube, das kriegst du mit fast jeder halbwegs aktuellen Grafikkarte hin.
Haben wir schon über das neue tolle Windows, meinst du Recall?
Ja, da habe ich ein Video zu aufgemacht eben.
Von der CT.
Das können wir uns gleich mal angucken.
Hier, das da.
Ich habe nur mitgekriegt, dass es für arme Windows-User kommt.
Aber nicht für normale x86-Desktop-User.
Das ist jetzt auch per Default nicht aktiviert worden.
Aber wir kennen es ja, Salami-Taktik.
Salami-Taktik.
Wenn es erstmal da ist, ist es da.
Vielleicht brauche ich doch irgendwelche GitHub-Windows-Deep-Loader in Zukunft, wenn so ein Scheiß aktuell geplant ist, dass es standardmäßig reinkommt.
Weil da habe ich gar keinen Bock drauf.
Ich habe echt keinen Bock drauf, dass man Windows ungefragt Screenshots von meinem Desktop macht und bei Microsoft hochlädt.
Also, habt ihr da Bock drauf?
Ich glaube, gibt es auf der Welt irgendjemand, der da Bock drauf hat?
Außer Microsoft.
Die haben da Bock drauf.
Bill Gates, den juckt das eh nicht.
Der ist mit 5G-Chips und Corona genug beschäftigt.
Wobei, das ist er auch nicht mehr.
Der baut jetzt Atomreaktoren, habe ich gehört.
Bill Gates.
Der baut jetzt irgendeinen Mini-Atomreaktor oder sowas.
Habe ich nur ganz kurz in News aufgeschnappt.
Also, keine Ahnung, was da eigentlich abgeht.
Weiß nicht, warum es jetzt ausgerechnet, jetzt irgendwie, wenn die gesamte Welt eher so auf erneuerbare Energien steht.
Atomreaktoren wieder im Trend sind, aber Bill Gates?
Der wird schon wissen, was er macht.
Mit Sicherheit gibt es dort irgendwelche komischen Registry-Sachen, die du einstellen kannst.
Garantiert.
Aber dass sowas default kommt.
Wir machen einen Screenshot und laden es bei Microsoft hoch.
Also von deinem Desktop, ganz ehrlich.
Selbst wenn es opt-in wäre bei default,
Das ist eine gute Frage. Weniger, weniger. Ich meine, Microsoft ist so viel wert wie noch nie. Also wobei man sagen muss, übrigens Apple ist auch nicht mal das teuerste Unternehmen der Welt, so laut Aktienstellt, sondern ich glaube mittlerweile ist es sogar, wurden die kurzzeitig oder wurden überholt von Nvidia.
Nvidia macht ja massive Stonks, mein ETF freut's, aber Microsoft hat eigentlich gar kein, das ist komisch, ne, so ziemlich alles hat so die richtig krassen Hardcore-Fanboys.
Apple, keine Frage, die haben wahrscheinlich so mit eines der hardcoreigsten Fanboys, die es gibt und Fangirls und ansonsten auch Sony und Playstation-User, Nintendo-User,
aber so richtig.
Richtig krasse Microsoft-Fanboys habe ich jetzt in letzter Zeit nicht mehr oder nur ganz selten gesehen, nachdem die Xbox ja gefühlt auch irgendwie komplett weg vom Telster ist.
Also ich frage immer noch, wie krass man so von der 360 bis heute verkacken konnte mit der Xbox.
Einfach die beste Konsole gehabt und dann abgeschissen.
Erinnert sich noch einer an diese Xbox One-Presentation, wo sie mit irgendwelchen Football-Games und Fernseh-Overlays und so einem Blödsinn versucht haben zu punkten?
Ich frage mich, ob das heute überhaupt noch theoretisch funktionieren würde, wenn man das benutzen würde.
Das komische Kachel-Menü war der Anfang vom Ende.
Die Xbox 360 hat auch fünf verschiedene UIs gehabt.
Sag mal, wie lang macht der eigentlich hier mein Icon-Theme-Installations-Stelz?
Oh ne, jetzt habe ich Q gedrückt, das war eine schlechte Idee.
Sprich, da klar, mach es nochmal neu.
Ja, weiß.
Ah ja.
Ja, und ansonsten, Chatgear, habe ich irgendwas Wichtiges verpasst?
War sonst noch irgendwas Wichtiges die Woche?
Ich suche immer noch nach einer guten IT-News-Overview für jede Woche, die bis Sonntag morgens raus ist.
Immer noch nichts gefunden.
Ich habe auf Twitter...
Ach Quatsch, ich kann euch gar nicht mehr zeigen, weil Twitter mittlerweile einfach so sackt und auch gar nicht mehr Twitter heißt.
Und du keine Antworten mehr siehst.
Ich habe seit Jahren mal wieder...
Fußball geguckt, das Eröffnungsspiel von der EM.
Und das erste, was mir aufgefallen ist, da gibt es AliExpress-Werbung und Alipay-Werbung.
Also die China-Chinesen sind da auch am Start.
Habe ich ein Screenshot gemacht, vorne auf Twitter gepostet.
Ich habe sinngemäß geschrieben, endlich mal Werbung für was Gescheites.
Die AliExpress-China-Chinesen sind am Start.
Oder sowas sinngemäß.
Ich habe ich...
Ja, das kam natürlich immer als Antwort.
Musst du aufpassen, wenn du sowas im Chat postest.
Ich bin mir sicher, hier sind irgendwelche AI-Analyse-Tools am Start, die dich dann fliegen.
Fliegen als Bot.
Zumindest habe ich das gepostet.
Und da kamen irgendwelche komischen Leute mit ganz komischen Antworten.
So als hätte ich das gepostet, um die Leute zu belehren.
Also mittlerweile sind sie auf Twitter echt von allem getriggert.
Die haben das so verstanden, ich wollte das quasi flecht reden.
Weil es Chinesen sind.
Hä?
Ich habe das eins zu eins so gemeint, wie ich es gepostet habe.
Ich bestelle seit Jahren schon bei AliExpress.
Und ich habe jetzt...
Ich habe das auch wieder bei AliExpress bestellt.
Und die waren saumäßig schnell.
Ich habe für uns im Stream zum Basteln bestellt.
Eines der besten Microcontroller, die man sich aktuell kaufen kann in Kombination.
Und zwar habe ich mir bestellt ein T-Display S3 für 15 Euro.
Inklusive Versand.
Hier.
Genau.
Der Screenshot ist richtig kacke hier.
Und das hier...
Wir müssen uns...
Wir müssen uns das...
Wir müssen uns das bei denen auf der Homepage angucken.
Sonst sind die Screenshots bei AliExpress Schrott.
Und zwar gibt es...
Das ist richtig, richtig nice.
Hier kostet es sogar 1,20 Dollar.
Das ist der aktuell schnellste ESP32, den es gibt von Espressif.
Mit einem semi ganz guten Display.
Ich habe es hier liegen.
Warte mal.
Wie geht denn das auf?
Ja.
Das Display macht auch...
Das macht echt einen ganz brauchbaren Eindruck.
Was, by the way, was nicht stimmt ist...
Das Display hat kleine runden Ecken.
Ich habe, glaube ich, den mit dem etwas größeren Display dran.
Gibt es, glaube ich, in drei Varianten.
Ich glaube, ich habe ein bisschen...
Zumindest mein Display ist viereckig.
Und ein bisschen größer als das.
Ja.
Was ich damit vorhabe...
Das ausprobieren, weil ich die ganze Zeit schon an der alten Version damit rumprogrammiere.
Also...
Ich habe einen sinnvollen Anwendungszweck dafür.
Und einen nicht so sinnvollen Anwendungszweck für.
Und zwar...
Der sinnvolle Anwendungszweck für ist...
Ich will den Raspberry Pi, den ich im Keller stehen habe, etwas aufsplitten.
Der macht ja 3000 Sachen.
Und wenn der abkackt, dann funktioniert einiges nicht zum Steuern im Keller.
Ich würde zumindest...
Eine Sache...
Gerne auslagern auf den ESP32.
Und das Ding wird dann im Keller gehängt.
Mit einem Analog-Digital-Converter dran.
Und auf dem Display zeige ich dann halt einfach den aktuellen gemessenen Wert an.
So nichts Großartiges.
Aber ich wollte ja mal probieren.
Und das ist das, was ich die letzten paar Tage auch schon programmiert habe.
Ein bisschen so vor mich hin.
Ich wollte mal...
Einen eigenen WiFi-Manager für den ESP32 programmieren.
Also ein Web-Interface.
Was...
Das Ding macht einen Access-Point auf.
Es gibt ein Web-Interface über HTTPS.
Da kannst du dein WLAN-Passwort vergeben.
Es gibt 1000 Projekte in der Richtung.
Aber ich habe sowas noch nie selbst gemacht.
Und es ist immer schön mal ein bisschen sowas zu machen, was man nicht gemacht hat.
Zumindest ist das Ding von der Ausstattung her richtig, richtig nice.
Also es ist massiver Overkill für simple Projekte.
Aber ihr müsst euch mal angucken, was da drin ist.
Die Beschreibungen hier von denen sind schon...
Sind ziemlich hängen geblieben.
Mal gucken, ob hier mehr steht.
Was ist das?
Was ist das, was da drin ist?
Geil.
Die haben noch nicht mal ein ordentliches...
Nehmen wir ein ordentliches Datasheet, was man hier sieht.
Also.
Das Ding hat...
Pass mal auf.
Das ist eigentlich richtig high IQ, das Ding.
So.
Das Ding hat...
Ein...
Gibt es das vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen...
Ja, hier ist glaube ich die bessere Übersicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum die Webseiten so schlecht sind.
Wer hat diese Webseiten wieder gebaut, Mann?
Vielleicht sieht man hier ein Overview...
Zumindest, ich kann es euch auch aus dem Kopf erzählen.
Also, ich suche eine gute Hardware-Spec-Overview vom ESP32S.
Das Ding hat...
Zwei Dual-Cores mit bis zu 240 MHz.
Das hatten die Alten übrigens auch.
Ich bin mir sogar relativ sicher, dass man die Neuen sogar bis zu 280 MHz laufen lassen kann.
Es gibt übrigens mittlerweile...
Sogar ESP8266.
Die haben...
160 MHz CPU.
Single-Core-CPU habe ich gesagt.
Ja, das hier ist so viel auf einmal.
Das hier ist so viel auf einmal.
Ich wollte einfach eine normale...
Übersicht haben.
Du bekommst 2x42 MHz CPUs.
Neuere Version als auf deinem alten ESP32.
Du bekommst einen zusätzlichen Kern.
Ultra-Low-Core-Prozessor.
Der mehr kann als der Alte.
Du bekommst leider...
Kein 5 GHz WiFi.
Du bekommst aber ansonsten das Aktuellste an WiFi und Bluetooth-Hardware.
Man bekommt 8 MB extra RAM.
Das ist extrem nice.
Für grafische Ausgaben auf Displays.
Der normale ESP32 hatte nur 520 KB RAM.
Und das Ding hat jetzt 8 MB.
Das ist einfach mal...
Für Milliardenfach...
Ne, nicht wirklich.
Für 20-fach ungefähr so.
Naja, nicht ganz.
Für 16-fach oder so.
Und das ist, wenn man hier was mit Display hat.
Und eine Auflösung von...
170x320.
Da braucht man ein bisschen RAM.
Dass man ordentlich das Display überhaupt benutzen kann.
Das finde ich sehr nice.
Und das Ding ist halt schnell.
Also das ist...
Nichts...
Jetzt für Leute, die einfach einen ultra cheapen Microcontroller brauchen.
Aber ein bisschen was advanceres machen will.
Ist das glaube ich aktuell.
Und auch dieses Board mit dem Display.
Eines der besten Grundlagen, was man für Projekte verwenden kann.
Ja.
Das Ding hat standardmäßig einen niedrigen Deep Sleep Current.
Da braucht man keine extra Boards mehr.
Das Ganze geht jetzt mittlerweile über USB-Anschluss.
Nicht mehr über USB zu Serial.
Ja.
Direkten Batterieeingang, alles.
Das ist richtig nice.
Das ist quasi so das Flagship.
Den Flagship.
Sag mal.
Wie lange geht denn das Update noch?
Flagship Controller, den die gerade haben.
Und ich finde, es geht voll klar mit 15 Euro.
Für...
Hier von AliExpress.
Finde ich geht voll klar 15 Euro für das Board.
Übrigens, meins sieht auch so aus.
Mit einem viereckigen Dis...
Ne.
Ne, meins sieht nicht so aus.
Egal, mein Display ist auch ein Ticken größer.
Whatever.
Die Anzeigen sind wieder super, super pepega.
Ja, so sieht...
So sieht meins aus.
Genau.
Ist schon ein kleiner...
Die Chinesen faken wieder ein bisschen.
Ist schon ein kleiner Unterschied, oder?
Zwischen diesen Dingen.
Achso, die gibt's schon...
Gibt es irgendwie in verschiedenen Varianten oder so.
Na gut.
Oh, wir haben es geschafft.
Ich darf meine Packages installieren.
Nice.
Ja.
Hast du den Twitch-CEO-Stream gesehen, wo er...
Opa geleakt...
Was?
Wer hat wen geleakt?
Nein.
Keine Ahnung.
Hat er...
Hat er aus Versehen ein...
Pool-Stream aufgemacht, oder wie?
Ne, hab ich nicht gesehen.
Home Assistant hat Roadmap rausgebracht.
Okay.
Zeig mal.
Ja, aber warum leakt er das als Twitch-CEO in dem Stream?
Wie...
Wie kommt er...
Wie kommt er dazu?
Home Assistant Roadmap.
Okay, lass mal schnell gucken.
Wir müssen das mal kurz hier rüber packen.
Dark Reader.
Ja.
Schon besser.
Können das auch.
Einfach in der VM aufmachen.
Also.
Roadmap for Home Assistant.
Haben die gepostet?
Vor ein paar Tagen.
Gibt keine Comments.
Ah, doch.
Das ist ja dieses...
Dieses dumme Forum.
Dieses...
TERROR FORUM.
Okay.
Our Roadmap!
Roadmap.
Ah.
Roadmap, hier.
Okay.
Die Roadmap.
Was wollen sie haben?
Now.
Make customization of dashboards easy intuitive.
Okay.
Das finde ich gut.
Das ist das, was für die Noobs...
Was für die Noob-User gut ist, dass das schön shiny aussieht und man das GUI ordentlich
konfigurieren kann.
Find ich gut.
Äh, Voice assistants.
Ehm.
Ah, ich...
Ich seh, ich seh Sachen!
Voice Assistant, ja, ganz ehrlich, ich bin ja, ihr wisst ja, ich bin ja kein großer Fan von allen möglichen Voice Assistants.
Also ich habe weder hier Google noch Alexa noch irgendwas anderes am Start.
Oder ich benutze auch kein Siri auf dem iPhone.
Man muss es eingeschaltet haben für CarPlay, aber ich benutze das nicht.
Ich habe es auch nicht auf Listen Mode.
Also da bin ich, juckt mich jetzt persönlich nicht so.
Automation Easy Up, das ist gut.
Es ist schon deutlich besser geworden.
Vielleicht erinnert sich der ein oder andere noch dran, früher musste man seine Automations in Home Assistant in YAML erstellen.
Das musste man jedes Mal seine Home Assistant Configuration reloaden, war richtig für den Arsch.
Danach konnte man YAML Configuration reloaden und dann konnte man es endlich im Web Interface konfigurieren.
Aber da gibt es noch einiges zu optimieren.
Also das Automation Workflow ist noch nicht so perfekt.
Deswegen haben ja viele Leute sich noch umgeschwenkt auf Node-RED und sowas.
Ich gucke mir gerade an, was du gepostet hast.
Er hat irgendwie Probleme, was anderes zu finden, oder?
Dann gibt es Default Dashboards, mehr useful, ja das ist für Einsteiger auch gut.
Hier Voice Assistant, juckt mich nicht, Automation Easy.
Ja gut, das ist ja ultra, ultra high level, die Roadmap.
Boah, das lese ich mir jetzt nicht alles durch.
Aber die Roadmap ist super high level gewesen.
So, hat er jetzt eigentlich alles updated?
Kann ich jetzt neu starten?
Leute!
Was ich gemacht habe, als ich den Stream gestartet habe, ist Pac-Man Update und, was ist?
Arsch, by the way, neue Package Updates.
Kannst zehnmal am Tag aktualisieren, wenn du willst.
So, ich wollte eigentlich irgendwas sagen, vorhin noch, aber ich habe es zwischendurch gesidetrackt.
Keine Ahnung.
Also wir machen nachher auf jeden Fall Bastelstream.
Und dann müssen wir C++ proggern.
Das wird was.
Weil, wie gesagt, ich habe die letzten Tage daran schon rumgebastelt.
Und wir machen das jetzt im Schnelldurchgang nochmal zusammen, dass ihr auch was von habt.
Das Schöne ist, wenn ich C++ programmieren muss, da raste ich immer aus bei.
Wenn ich mich allerdings, wenn ich abgucken kann, was ich selbst schon gebaut habe, dann ist es nicht so schlimm.
Dann habe ich nämlich den ganzen Mist schon hinter mir.
Boah, chill free.
So, dann lasst uns nochmal schnell gucken, was trendet auf Shithub denn.
Coolify trendet.
Das wollte ich mir auch mal angucken.
Beziehungsweise, ich habe schon mal ganz kurz reingeguckt bei der Demo.
Ist ein cooles Projekt.
Gibt es schon eine ganze Weile.
Habe ich auch schon vor einer Weile schon mal gesehen.
Aber mittlerweile scheint es echt auf dem Stand zu sein, dass man das sinnig verwenden kann.
Moment, ist das ein PHP Projekt?
No, God!
Please, no!
Okay, jetzt habe ich gleich viel weniger Bock drauf.
Nee, Laravel ist okay.
PHP geht auch klar.
Das ist nicht so, dass es jetzt schlimm ist.
Letztendlich ist es mir auch egal, in welchem Backend die dafür benutzen.
Das ist ein Webinterface zum Selbsthosten von Anwendungen, um es mal ganz grob zu sagen.
Wobei es eher in die Richtung geht, dass du sowas wie, dass du sowas wie Netlify selbst hast oder was soll.
Dass du dann, dass du im Prinzip einfach nur noch auswählst.
Ich will jetzt eine .NET-Anwendung deployen.
Hier ist mein Repo mit Docker-File.
Das ist mein Branch für Test.
Das ist mein Branch für Brot.
Und jetzt mach mal.
Nee, nee, nee, nicht so wie Plesk.
So wie Netlify ungefähr.
Da gibt es eine Demo von hier.
Hat man eine Demo?
Weiß ich nicht.
Was ist da eine Demo von?
Oder hatte ich es mal irgendwo gestartet oder so?
Screenshots?
Es ist ein bisschen wie Netlify.
Wir probieren das.
Wir probieren das mal aus.
Also wenn man...
Eigene Anwendungen hat.
Das ist für so kleinen Kram.
Den man laufen lassen möchte.
Entweder privat oder public.
Ist das nice.
Das kümmert sich auch um Domain-Handling und Zertifikats-Handling.
Alles mit.
Du kannst damit alles deployen, was ein Docker-File hat.
Finde ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Das müssen wir uns aber mal in Ruhe angucken.
Das kann man jetzt nicht so einfach übers Knie brechen und sagen.
Wir machen mal...
Ich bitte mich ein.
Ich habe mal eine Demo davon gesehen.
Oder war das was anderes?
Ja, das trendet.
Das trendet das, was ich gesehen habe, auch zurecht.
Da bin ich wirklich gespannt drauf.
Das probieren wir demnächst mal aus.
Guck mal hier.
Man könnte sagen, das Projekt hat Anfang 2024 doch etwas an Fahrt aufgenommen, oder?
Das lag aber auch mit daran, dass Fireship das erwähnt hat.
Ein paar andere Influencers Werbung dafür gemacht haben.
Also Werbung.
Das kann man ja...
Das ist nicht Paid-Werbung.
Zumindest glaube ich das nicht gesehen zu haben.
Sondern die haben das vorgestellt.
Und dann ging es hier steil bergauf.
Richtig stonks.
Ja.
Gibt es eigentlich neue Issues?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Alles perfekt.
Also was trendet denn hier?
Zeigt mal ja.
Letzte...
Das ist diese Woche.
Okay.
AI.
Skippen wir.
Das hier gucken wir uns an.
In einem der nächsten Streams.
AI.
Comfy UI.
Wim.
Distri...
Verstehe ich nicht, wo man...
Warum man das braucht.
Wenn man Wim benutzt, beziehungsweise irgendwie, dann will man das auch selbst konfigurieren.
AIDA.
Ah.
AI.
Canva.
Shell.
Stelz.
AI.
Build your own X.
Die meinen nicht, dass man da Twitter mit nachbaut, oder?
Das ist...
Das ist einfach so eine...
So eine Übersicht.
Wie man...
Okay.
AI.
Terminal für Android.
Finde ich interessant, dass das ausgerechnet jetzt trendet.
Das ist schon uralt.
Aber nice.
Eines der besten Android-Apps.
Kann man Bash-Skript unter Android verwenden.
Und auch sich per SSH darüber einloggen in Android.
Und auf seine Android-Kiste und da was.
Das ist echt praktisch.
Also wenn man Android automatisieren will, ist das hier eines der besten Tools.
Cyber ist auch schon uralt.
DuckDB.
Habe ich bei NativeWeb.
Ein Video zugesehen.
Und wollten wir uns auch demnächst angucken.
Übrigens, Leute.
Ich glaube.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Vielleicht ist...
Vielleicht...
Vielleicht ist YouTube auch einfach nur super pepega.
Ihr erinnert euch ja noch dran.
Dass ich ein paar...
Aber jetzt nicht absichtlich, ja.
Ein paar blöde Comments im Stream gemacht habe.
Über...
Wie der Presenter von NativeWeb im Video guckt.
Wie Golo guckt im Video.
Und das...
Tut mir echt leid.
Das ist immer noch ein bisschen...
Ist mir immer noch ein bisschen peinlich, ja.
Ich wusste nicht, dass er sich das...
Dass er da...
Ja...
Wie soll man sagen?
So...
History hat mit Leuten, die sowas über ihn sagen.
Zumindest ich glaube...
Ich habe jetzt die letzten zwei Videos...
Kommentare unter die NativeWeb-Videos geschrieben.
Ich glaube, ich bin gebannt.
Die sind nicht aufgetaucht.
Ich habe auch noch das DuckDB-Video in Comment geschrieben.
Sogar zwei, weil ich gedacht habe, YouTube spinnt.
Und...
Mal gucken, ob sie mittlerweile da sind.
Ja, hier habe ich einen Comment drunter geschrieben.
Ist nie aufgetaucht.
Ja.
Oder das Neueste mit Twitter auch.
Also entweder spinnt YouTube richtig.
Oder er hat mich gebannt.
Aber ich meine...
Das war keine Absicht, ja.
Ich sage halt manchmal blödes Zeug.
So spontan.
Und ich dachte jetzt nicht, dass das dazu führt, dass ich gebannt werde.
Gut, aber ich kann es nicht ändern.
Es wäre auf jeden Fall sadge, wenn ich gebannt wäre.
Aber das war nicht so gemeint.
Aber was soll ich machen, ja?
Zumindest DuckDB hat ein Video zugeguckt und wollte ich mir auch mal angucken.
Wobei ich da echt gespannt drauf bin, wie gut das mit dem Embedden funktioniert.
Das ist auch ein Punkt, der mir bei mir...
SQLite lässt sich ja erstmal vordergründig ganz gut embedden.
Aber sobald du irgendwelche Single Binary Applications bauen möchtest, wird das eklig.
Gerade in Go wird das eklig, weil SQLite C-Go Bindings braucht.
Und sobald du C-Go verwendest, sind deine Go Binaries auch automatisch von deiner System-C-Library abhängig.
Und du hast wieder die ganzen Probleme, die du mit jeder anderen Anwendung verwendest.
auch hast wenn du sie standalone machen willst ja es gibt es gibt einen sq lite port nach go
aber das ist auch nicht der weiße als letzter schluss deswegen bin ich mal gespannt ob die
das mit dac db besser gelöst haben wie man das ganze embedden kann ich bin mal gespannt ob es
dort bessere möglichkeiten gibt dass das zu integrieren als bei sq lite ja auch wenn man
das sind wir auch wenn man es geladen dort net verwenden will man braucht ja immer noch die
irgendwo die die die sql library es wäre halt cool wenn es wirklich eine richtig echte datenbank gibt
die im bett bar ist weiß nicht wie das genau funktionieren soll aber wäre na ist also keine
ahnung wie das gelöst haben da bin ich gespannt drauf das gucken wir uns auch an sondern gibt
es irgend
eine proxy geschichte und dann gibt es wenn csv warum nicht einfach gleich chasen oder inny files
also diese woche die ein oder anderen coolen projekte wenigstens dabei lasst mal kurz gucken
was was heute trennt dachte die verwenden jetzt alle playwright puppeteers out ok nix so spannendes
alles klar ob wieder neue package updates gibt wir haben schon drei sekunden nicht mehr aktualisiert
jetzt nicht
hast du eigentlich gesehen dass twitter jetzt offiziell die brauchen geld anscheinend habe ich
nicht gesehen gibt es da gibt es dann gibt es da eine news zu auf wegen der seite die selbst keine
buber enthält die man aufmachen kann ich muss mal kurz bei mir gucken ob ein zweiter twitter
wobei es gab schon immer titelbilder und so auf twitter aber natürlich bei weitem nicht so präsent
ich glaube es war nie verboten in dem sinne
wie gesagt war ja war im prinzip schon immer so ich meine wenn die jetzt anfangen das präsenter
zu platzieren und irgendwie dann auch selbst monetarisieren wollen und so da wird es natürlich
dann schon ein bisschen problematisch dann müssen wir das gut finde weil ich habe kein bock dass ich
twitter aufmache in der u-bahn oder so mal kurz mein feed refreshen oder irgendwelche dick dicks
oder boobas oder was anderes in der kamera hängen habe ja also das ist mal das mindeste und dann müssen wir ordentlich filmen
dann die brauchen geld bei x die könnten sich auch einfach wieder zurück ob die
könnten sich auch einfach wieder zu twitter umbenennen hat zwischen
gescheiten namen weil x ist so ein drecks rahmen kannst du vor allem nicht
mal richtig danach suchen
terms of service of society genau aber das durfte dass sie das ging doch schon
immer das war also ganz ehrlich twitter nude pictures und so gab es doch schon
immer wusste gar nicht dass das offiziell nicht erlaubt ist
letzt also man muss sagen also meine twitter timeline ja die war wirklich
sehr wild die letzten tage über also eines der abgedrehten sachen war da
habe ich auch wo passen eigentlich gerade zum thema passend zum thema ja
ich habe meine timeline refreshed und auf einmal ist dort ein bild von einer
in so einem korsett
mit mit relativ prominenten push up buber ja und peitsche in der hand und
sinngemäß stand in dem tweet wer jetzt auf dieses bild spritzt und ein foto und
mir da ein foto von postet der bekommt auf onlyfans ein kostenloses titelbild
da war es bescheiden in welche richtung twitter geht
es gibt bestimmt genug die die finden das nice das twitter jetzt auch sich
diesen content erschließt die onlyfans finden das gut da kannst du noch aktiver
das profil bewerben auf twitter dann na ja mal gucken wie es das ganze
entwickelt also ich finde gar nicht dass alles schlechtes was ich bei twitter
geändert hat aber das mit abstand größte für mich und nervigste ist der name change
Das wird für mich auch immer Twitter sein.
Und Alternativen kannst du ja im Prinzip auch vergessen.
Threads, Threads oder wie das heißt von Facebook, keine Ahnung, ob das noch überhaupt irgendjemand verwendet.
Das verwenden wahrscheinlich die üblichen Facebook-Boomer, die auch zu Ostern unanständige Eierwitze posten und sich furchtbar lustig finden.
Außerdem, dann gibt es noch, ja, Mastadon und das Zeug, was im Prinzip auch bis auf ein paar Technik-Begeisterte irgendwie auch keiner großartig benutzt.
War nicht eines der ersten Sachen, die auf Twitter mal entfernt wurden, als jemand die Flugroute von Elons Jet gepostet hat.
Und wisst ihr, Reddit, muss ich sagen, an sich ist ja wirklich, auch nach all den Jahren, ist Reddit immer noch eine ganz nice Plattform.
Eine Sache, die mich an Reddit allerdings echt stört, ist, ich habe keine Ahnung, wer diese Mobile-App designt.
Die ist schon besser als früher, ja.
Versteht mich nicht falsch.
Man kann die Reddit-Mobile-App mittlerweile verwenden.
Man braucht ja mittlerweile auch keine alternativen Clients mehr, weil Reddit das abgestellt hat.
Alternative Clients gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Aber ich frage mich ernsthaft, wer diese Mobile-App designt.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ihr Reddit, wenn ihr die Reddit-App aufmacht,
ich weiß nicht, ob man davon irgendwelche Bilder findet,
ja, hier, vielleicht offiziellen Screenshots, keine Ahnung, ja, super.
Es ist geil, dass man Screenshots von einer App sieht, die nichts mit der eigentlichen App zu tun hat.
Auch geil, oder?
Nichts davon.
Nichts davon ist ein eigentlicher Screenshot der App.
Screenshots, ja klar, nichts.
Okay, das hier war mal, also, auch richtig hängen geblieben.
Zumindest, so ein Ding, wenn man Twitter aufmacht, äh, nicht Twitter, wenn man Reddit aufmacht,
auf iOS.
Okay, dann startet man mit so einer Übersichtsseite, so einer Landingpage, so einer Startpage,
wo quasi so eine Art Feed läuft, wo du die Reddit-Posts gezeigt kriegst,
von denen Reddit denkt, dass sie dich interessieren.
So, das Problem ist nur, dort kann man dann nach links und rechts swipen,
gefühlt unendlich lang.
Und es gibt keine Eins-Anzeige, auf welcher Seite man eigentlich gerade ist.
Ja, das sind nämlich unterschiedliche Seiten.
Also, man kann hier durchswitchen zwischen personalisiertem Feed, globalem Feed, Trending-Feed,
irgendwelchen komischen Dingern, wo ich nicht mal weiß, was es ist.
Und man hat irgendwo, man hat immer eine Anzeige, was es ist.
Also, ganz ehrlich, wer diese App designt für iOS, dem ist echt nicht mehr zu helfen.
Also, die Reddit-App ist wirklich grausam.
Und was auch grausam geworden ist, hier, keine Ahnung.
Reddit-JavaScript, was auch grausam ist, teilweise, ist die Web-Experience von Reddit.
Ganz besonders auf Mobile-Browser, was man, glaube ich, gar nicht so richtig...
Wo ist der Knopf dafür? Hier, gell?
Was man gar nicht so richtig nachstellen kann auf dem Desktop,
weil man halt hier trotzdem den Desktop-Browser drunter hat.
Und ich bin mir bei Reddit, ohne Scheiß, ich bin mir zu 99% sicher,
dass Reddit eine Detail-App hat.
Also, wenn man hier die Webseite zur Detection eingebaut hat,
ob du per Mobile-Safari oder Mobile-Browser darauf zugreifst.
Und die machen die Webseite absichtlich kaputt, wenn du per Mobile drauf gehst.
Anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären, dass beispielsweise Buttons erst beim dritten Mal klicken funktionieren.
Dass beim Scrollen der Post zugeht und so was.
Das ist so... Das ist auch übrigens nicht auf dem Desktop feststellbar.
Es ist nur auf Mobile-Browser feststellbar.
Und das sind so Dinge, wo ich mir denke,
das das muss irgendwie absichtlich kaputt gemacht werden sondern so einen
random break randomizer auf mobile apps aber new reddit com ist doch das gleiche
reddit wie das default reddit oder oder nicht chat ist reddit etwas anderes
ok moment ist new reddit etwas anderes als reddit moment es gibt das ist das
gleiche oder dass das das redirected mich oder geht das oder geht das nur
ups oder geht das nur wenn man mobile view hat also ich habe hier kein new
also wenn überhaupt wenn überhaupt dann old reddit aber old reddit hat auch so seine
probleme zumindest das ist das das ist auch schon hochgradig hochgradig kaputt
hier wenn ich mir das so angucke
zumindest
old reddit
gibt es noch old reddit geht noch also was die bei reddit teilweise da designen ist mir auch nicht so ganz klar aber am schlimmsten ohne scheiß am schlimmsten ist die mobile app sonst geht das klar reddit aber an sich ist eine gute plattform was ich bei reddit gar nicht checke ist habt ihr das auch manchmal dass ihr bei reddit so random videos zwischendurch empfohlen kriegt von irgendwelchen leuten die dann gitarre spielen oder ihre mäuse filmen oder sowas wo ich mich immer so denke warum taucht es jetzt auf warum gibt es das überhaupt auf reddit
und was will mir reddit damit sagen
und was will mir reddit damit sagen wobei es in letzter zeit nicht mal so oft
wobei es in letzter zeit nicht mal so oft
wobei es in letzter zeit nicht mal so oft vorgekommen ist vielleicht hat reddit das
vorgekommen ist vielleicht hat reddit das
vorgekommen ist vielleicht hat reddit das auch abgeschafft vielleicht vielleicht ein
auch abgeschafft vielleicht vielleicht ein
auch abgeschafft vielleicht vielleicht ein reddit auch reddit video kam wurde reddit
reddit auch reddit video kam wurde reddit
reddit auch reddit video kam wurde reddit video eingestellt oder wie das heißt oder
video eingestellt oder wie das heißt oder
video eingestellt oder wie das heißt oder reddit live hieß das doch oder live das
reddit live hieß das doch oder live das
Das sind so Livestreams, ja?
Ach ja.
Ne, Live-Chat.
Okay, Live-Channels sind weg.
Also keine Ahnung, was das denn mal gewesen ist, ja?
Ja.
Aber an sich, Reddit, echt noch eine ganz brauchbare Plattform.
Eine, die sich die letzten Jahre über
eher verbessert hat als verschlechtert.
Gerade was Verfügbarkeit angeht und sowas.
Und auch Twitch.
Ich weiß, Twitch bekommt ja immer viel Hate.
Aber auch nicht alles bei Twitch ist schlechter geworden
seit der Amazon-Übernahme.
Also man merkt eindeutig die bessere technische Grundlage
mittlerweile bei Twitch.
Twitch kackt bei weitem nicht mal so viel ab wie früher.
Ja, es gibt auch viele Sachen auf Twitch,
die ich immer noch sehr blöd finde.
Aber es ist nicht alles super kacke.
Und viele Leute verbinden natürlich auch,
wenn die sagen, Twitch war früher so viel besser.
Viele Leute verbinden das natürlich auch mit der ersten Zeit,
wo sie zum ersten Mal auf Live-Chat
aufmerksam geworden sind.
Das ist natürlich was anderes.
Ich finde Twitch eigentlich immer noch ganz brauchbar.
Ja.
Yep, Clock.
So, eine Kunde.
Askequarium zum Beruhigen.
Ich muss mal kurz was trinken, Chat.
Und dann gucken wir uns ein paar YouTube-Videos an.
Mal schauen, was wir da so haben.
Chat, ich muss euch noch was sehr Sättge.
Massive Sättge.
Warum habe ich Sättge eigentlich gar nicht?
Als Sättge.
Ah ja, Hi-Rez, Hi-Rez-Sättge.
Hi-Rez, Hi-Rez-Sättge.
Ich muss euch noch was sehr Sättges erzählen.
Wo mir wieder auffällt, dass ich echt alt bin mittlerweile, ja.
Ich werde 40 bald in ein paar Monaten.
Aber nee, das ist nicht das, was Sättge ist.
Ich hatte in der Schule zwei recht gute Freunde,
mit denen ich viel gemacht habe.
Ich habe zu beiden keinen Kontakt.
Ich hatte keinen großartigen Kontakt mehr mittlerweile.
Aber es gab eigentlich zwei, mit denen ich hauptsächlich immer unterwegs war,
wie ich jung war.
Und der eine wollte es voll wissen.
Der hatte, glaube ich, der war 18 oder 17 oder so.
Moin, Javelin Brothers.
Hi.
Du bist gerade nicht zum richtigen Zeitpunkt gekommen.
Ich wollte gerade was Trauriges erzählen.
Also, wenn du keine schlechte Stimmung haben willst, dann zumindest.
Ein Freund von mir damals.
Der hat, glaube ich, irgendwie erst das Kind mit 18 gezeugt.
Der war wirklich saumützig früh dabei.
Erst das Kind mit 18 und dann hat er irgendwie noch ein paar Jahre...
Also, der war wirklich sehr, sehr aktiv, ja.
Sehr aktiv, was das angeht.
Und ich hatte dann auch jahrelang mit dem keinen Kontakt mehr.
Der frühe Hase, ja.
Ich hatte auch jahrelang mit dem keinen Kontakt mehr.
Und jetzt habe ich vor zwei Tagen, habe ich gehört,
dass er sich nicht mehr so gut fühlt.
Und ich habe dann auch jahrelang mit dem keinen Kontakt mehr.
Und jetzt habe ich vor zwei Tagen, habe ich gehört,
der hat sich umgebracht.
Und ich hatte mit dem zwar keinen Kontakt mehr, großartig,
aber irgendwie hat mich das schon etwas betroffen, persönlich, ja.
Ich meine, das war jemand, mit dem habe ich bestimmt...
Oh, lass es mal über zehn Jahre gewesen sein.
Jeden Tag irgendwas gemacht.
Wie gesagt, war ich klein.
Ich habe bestimmt die letzten, keine Ahnung,
die letzten 20 Jahre nichts mehr von dem gehört, ja.
Aber jetzt habe ich gehört, er hat sich umgebracht.
Und zwar hat sich wohl seine Frau von ihm getrennt,
seine zweite Frau oder so von ihm getrennt.
Und eine Woche später hat er sich umgebracht.
Und das hat mich jetzt doch persönlich etwas mitgenommen, ja.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich das jetzt ultra fertig machen würde,
aber wie gesagt, ich hatte seit 20 Jahren,
20 Jahre mit dem nichts zu tun.
Ehemaliger Freund von mir hat sich umgebracht.
Chillfreak.
Also wie gesagt, ich hatte 20 Jahre mit dem nichts großartig zu tun.
Aber das hat mich doch schon etwas belastet jetzt die letzten Tage über.
Also ich weiß nicht, was genau und so.
Und ich wollte es ja auch nicht fragen.
Hast du mitgekriegt?
Also da sieht man mal wieder,
der hat nie den Eindruck gemacht,
dass er irgendwie da psychisch irgendwie einen Schaden hätte oder so.
Zumindest nicht vor 20 Jahren, ja.
Aber es gibt doch Sachen, die können einen sehr mitnehmen anscheinend.
Also Leute, macht keinen Scheiß.
Bei sowas bin ich immer ganz froh,
dass ich mit,
dass ich mir den Stress mit Frau und Kind bis jetzt erspart habe.
Ja, also das hat mich echt ein bisschen beschäftigt die letzten Tage über.
Auch wenn ich mit dem, wie gesagt, 20 Jahre nichts zu tun hatte.
Ja, es gibt jetzt gar nicht so viel drüber zu erzählen.
Also zumindest ist das, ist das was, was ich echt was mich wundert,
dass einige Leute, die ich kannte und ich bin jetzt ja mit 39 auch noch nicht so alt,
dass es die, dass die nicht mehr leben.
Und das ist nicht der einzige.
Ja, es gibt noch mehr und ich so denkt, ey,
das kann auch ganz schnell alles mal in die Hose gehen.
Ja, was mit dem anderen ist noch nichts.
Ich habe mit den allen nichts, nicht mehr so viel mit den Leuten aus der Schule alle nicht mehr.
So viel zu tun gehabt.
Über 20 Jahre habe ich auch kein großartiges Interesse dran.
Denn den anderen gibt es aber noch.
Den anderen, mit dem ich früher öfters was gemacht.
Den gibt es noch.
Den habe ich letztes Mal hier im Ort Ort gesehen.
Ja, was auch immer.
Ich weiß nicht, was da war, aber schon heftig.
Sad Game.
Nun gut.
Ich reboot mal, weil rebooten kann man nie zu oft.
Man kann es nicht sagen.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Vielleicht war das auch gar nicht der Grund.
Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht kam einfach alles zusammen.
So, Browser, Terminal, zack, alles am Start.
Ja, dann schwenken wir mal wieder um auf etwas erfreulichere Sachen.
Muss auch kurz was anderes tatsächlich erfreuliches erzählen.
Und zwar Leute, wisst ihr, dass ich jetzt offiziell laut meiner Garmin App.
Moment, das dauert jetzt immer, bis sie lahm, bis die aufgeht.
So, Performance Stats.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass ich.
Laut meiner Garmin App jetzt ganz offiziell nicht mehr untrainiert bin.
Ich bin jetzt laut laut meiner Garmin App.
Wie heißt das auf Deutsch?
Durchschnitt.
Sagt jetzt ich bin 50 Prozent.
Also ich bin in den Top oder in den Top oder in den unteren, je nachdem, wie man das sieht, 50 Prozent meines Alters und.
Triggerwarnung Geschlecht steht bei Garmin so, aber man muss sagen, das ist natürlich nicht 50 Prozent der Gesamtbevölkerung.
Das ist 50 Prozent der Leute, die diese Garmin App für Sporttracking benutzen.
Also kann es von ausgehen, dass die Leute, die diese Garmin App dafür benutzen, eh schon ein bisschen mehr machen als die Durchschnittsbevölkerung.
Also ich werde wahrscheinlich mittlerweile.
Was?
Nee, geh ich auch nicht hin.
Lambo ist so eine scheiß Ecke.
Ähm, männlich gelesene Person.
Genau.
Ja, es ist teilweise echt schon abgedreht heute.
Ja, so und.
Ich habe jetzt einen VO2 Max laut Garmin von 42 und das ist genau Mittel.
Ich, ich, ich, ich bräuchte, glaube ich, einen von 44 oder 45, dass ich, dass es, dass ich gut bin.
Aber ich muss echt sagen, es geht die letzten.
Woche über echt richtig steil bergauf, was das angeht.
Wenn ich hier in die Race Predictions gucke, die Garmin App kann ja auch ungefähr sagen, so was sie denkt, was du zu Bestzeiten erreichen kannst.
Die sagt zum Beispiel, dass ich knapp 25 Minuten mittlerweile die 5K rennen könnte, wenn ich alles gebe.
Sehr nice eigentlich, ne?
Wie kann man denn den VO2 Max testen?
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass Garmin.
Das mit Statistik macht.
Und zwar.
Ich meine, die können dir ja kein Blut abnehmen und du hast keine Sauerstoff Maske auf und sowas.
Also direkt messen kann man das nicht.
Aber was Garmin natürlich machen kann, ist.
Garmin kann aufzeichnen, wie anstrengend deine Aktivität ist, bei wie viel Leistungs Output, weil es weiß dein Gewicht, weiß seine Größe, weiß seine Schrittlänge alles, weil ich für Leistungs Output du ungefähr welche Herzfrequenz hast.
Dann hat es diesen.
Dann hat es ja diesen Scanner auf der Haut.
Dass die quasi ungefähr sehen können, wie viel, wie viel Blut gerade so durchgepumpt wird.
Und dann gehe ich davon aus, aus diesen Werten haben die einfach Tabellen von Leuten, wo sie wirklich das gemessen haben und machen dann ganz viel Statistik und Rechnerei daraus, um dich irgendwie auf echte Messergebnisse zu mappen.
Deine Werte also ist davon auszugehen, dass das nicht hundertprozentig akkurat ist für dich, weil du kannst das realistisch.
Also messen kannst du es nur, wenn du eine Sauerstoffmaske aufkriegst und Blut abgenommen kriegst und sowas.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, durch die Menge, durch die riesen Menge der Daten, die Garmin hat mittlerweile und die Auswertung, die die gemacht haben, dass das trotzdem relativ akkurat ist.
Und wenn man sich Videos dazu anguckt, wo Leute auch wirklich sich testen lassen haben, plus ihre Garmin Werte sich angeguckt haben, dann war die Garmin Werte relativ nah an dem dran, was eben auch in der Realität gemessen wurde.
Das heißt, es ist glaube ich gar nicht mal so verkehrt, was da steht.
Nice Boys.
187.
Also geht runter.
Wie ich angefangen habe, ich habe angefangen mit 108.
108,5 vor zweieinhalb Jahren oder so.
Ich würde jetzt nochmal, du verlierst ja auch sau viel Wasser und alles Temporäre.
Was hast du für eine Garmin?
Ich habe die sogar noch hier auf.
Ich habe eine Garmin Forerunner 255 S.
Welche Körpergröße?
1,74.
Zirka, sagen wir mal so.
Wenn ich jetzt vielleicht...
Wenn wir mal so Durchschnittsgewicht, sagen wir mal, ich habe 88 Kilo, so zwischen 87 und 87, sagen wir mal 88 Kilo, 1,74.
Das heißt, ich bin immer noch zu dick, wenn es nach BMI und sowas geht.
Aber es ist ein ganz schöner Unterschied, ob man 88 Kilo wiegt versus 108.
Das ist echt ein ganz schöner Unterschied.
Man ist bei beidem zu dick, aber bei dem einen ist man viel zu dick und bei dem anderen ist man nur ein bisschen zu dick.
Ja, das ist schon...
Es ist schon nice.
Und eins muss ich sagen, das macht mir mittlerweile auch wirklich Spaß.
Das hätte ich nie gedacht.
Für mich war so alleine Sport machen, war so für mich...
Der Tag sei Dank.
Ich finde, das ist so eines der dümmsten Dinger, die man machen kann.
Das habe ich nie verstanden, so wie das Leute machen können.
Aber mittlerweile macht mir das wirklich Spaß.
Und wisst ihr, was das Beste ist?
Das Beste ist, wenn ich Leute überhole.
Bei der normalen Laufrunde.
Wenn ich Leute überhole.
Die halb so schwer und halb so jung sind wie ich.
Das ist richtig nice.
Halb so jung, halb so alt.
Halb so alt.
Nee, Fahrrad schieben durch Frankfurt nicht.
Ich werde das aber aufnehmen.
Wie gesagt, ich habe vor nächstes Wochenende mal gucken, ob das Wetter gut ist.
Lass mal kurz gucken, hier Wetter.
Hanau.
Gibt es noch Predictions für nächstes Wochenende?
Ja, schlecht.
Aber das kann man noch nicht sagen.
Also wenn das Wetter nächstes Wochenende gut ist, dann probiere ich 22 Kilometer, um genau zu sein,
von Hanau nach Seligenstadt zu laufen, am Mainradweg lang.
Und dann nehme ich die GoPro mit.
Das nehme ich auf.
Allerdings wird das eine ganze Weile dauern.
Ich kann das nicht am Stück aufnehmen.
Und es will ja auch keiner so lange gucken.
Ich werde dann irgendwas zusammenschneiden.
So nach dem Motto, Informatiker-Kellerkind rennt Halbmarathon.
Also Ziel ist, ich werde das super langsam laufen.
Weil 22 Kilometer sind echt eine Hausnummer und das geht auch ganz schön auf die Beine und sowas.
Also ich habe gesagt, ich werde das im Durchschnitt mit sieben Minuten pro Kilometer laufen.
Das müsste ich locker schaffen.
Das ist für mich wie nicht laufen.
Sieben Minuten pro Kilometer mittlerweile.
Ich werde am Ende doch wieder ein bisschen schneller laufen, weil es mir zu lahm vorkommt.
Aber ich muss mich echt zurückhalten, dass das hinhaut.
Ja, richtig.
Könnte es auch streamen?
Nee.
Dann habe ich vielleicht noch Leute, die auf einmal auf dem Weg auftauchen.
Ja.
Alles klar.
Dann.
Face-Leak-Video.
Nee, das war es nicht.
Habe ich vielleicht ein bisschen schlechte Pause-Posi erwischt, oder?
Okay, was ist das hier?
Vom Fließband in die IT.
Gehalt als Mitarbeiter im Digitalisierungsmanagement.
Oh je, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Das klingt...
Moment.
Digitalisierungsmanagement.
Ist das irgendwas vom Amt?
Nee, oder?
Was?
Wann kommt mal ein Video?
Ja, ich weiß.
Ich habe schon 130 Tage kein Video mehr hochgeladen.
Es wäre...
In einer der größten Molkereien in Deutschland.
Ist das...
Ist das Schwälbchen?
Gibt es doch, oder?
Schwälbchen-Molkerei.
Ja, ist es?
Übrigens, wisst ihr was witzig ist?
Äh...
So, so zum Thema Namen und Marken machen viel aus.
Es gibt so...
Von Schwälbchen gibt es so ziemlich alles.
Nur, dass da nicht überall Schwälbchen draufsteht.
Ich habe letztens...
Bei dem Laden, wo ich ab und zu mal Köfte futtere,
oder Döner-Teller oder sowas,
habe ich einen Ayran getrunken.
Und das Ding heißt...
Fragt mich nicht, ich kann kein Türkisch aussprechen.
Das heißt halt, irgendwie hat das einen coolen Namen auf Türkisch,
was da draufsteht.
So.
Irgendwas...
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich wird das irgendwas heißen,
wie super lecker auf Türkisch oder keine Ahnung.
So.
Alles auch super orientalisch aufgemacht und so.
Diese ganze Packung von dem Ayran, ja.
Und dann gucke ich hinten drauf.
Wo wurde das Ganze hergestellt?
Schwälbchen-Molkerei.
Manche Sachen verkaufen sich einfach mit der passenden...
Mit dem passenden Image drumherum
und dem passenden...
Besser.
So, also gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, was Sven im Digitalisierungsmanagement hat.
Der Sprung von Postbote auf IT, das ist schon 180 Grad Wende, würde ich mal sagen.
Das Schlimmste, was passieren kann, wenn unser komplettes Lager steht oder sowas.
Das wäre teurer Spaß.
Der Sprung von Postbote...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Kann man was gucken hier?
Aha.
Ich sehe schon.
Nice.
Ein Kabel-Headset-Enjoyer.
Der Sprung von Postbote...
Der Sprung von Postbote auf IT, das ist schon 180 Grad Wende, würde ich mal sagen.
Das Schlimmste, was passieren kann, wenn unser komplettes Lager steht oder sowas.
Das wäre teurer Spaß.
Ja, natürlich lohnt sich die Produktion hier vor Ort.
Ich finde es halt nur von der Aufmachung her lustig.
Verkauft sich mit Sicherheit besser.
Das ist auch Spaß.
Das geht schon im Millionenbereich.
Ich habe da vergessen, einen Minihaken zu setzen, der fatale Auswirkungen hat.
Ja, bei so einem...
Ganz ehrlich, bei so einem Interface...
Bei so einem Interface, da kann ich schon verstehen,
dass man da ab und zu mal vergisst,
irgendwelche Haken zu setzen.
Leute, hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung, auf was das hier basiert?
Ist das...
Das ist kein Windows Forms.
Ich...
Das ist vielleicht...
Oder?
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das irgendwas Java basiert.
Das ist sogar so hässlich, wie das aussieht.
Mal gespannt vielleicht.
Sieht ein bisschen nach...
Das kann sein.
Das sieht hässlich SAP aus.
Das kann gut sein.
...Haken zu setzen, der fatale Auswirkungen hat.
Hi.
Ich bin Sven, ich bin 25 Jahre alt, arbeite als Kaufmann für Digitalisierungsmanagement
in einer Mockerei in Schwarzenfeld und ihr dürft mich heute einen ganzen Tag lang begleiten.
.
Okay, Moment.
Nices Nerd-T-Shirt, glaube ich, mal, oder?
Was haben wir da?
Nee.
Doch, irgendwas.
Okay, das ist so advanced.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Ich bin dafür zuständig, Sachen zu digitalisieren, wie es auch das Berufsbild schon sagt.
Wir optimieren quasi Arbeitsprozesse.
Aber wir machen auch so simple Sachen, wie einfach Fehlerbehebungen von Usern.
Oder irgendein Festival, ja.
Ich bringe noch eben kurz das Telefon zum Kollegen, der Bereitschaft hat.
Ja.
Wenn der da ist, hoffentlich.
Ich habe dieses Wochenende glücklicherweise nichts.
Oh, guter Hinweis, Chatge.
Ich muss mal kurz checken.
Der bringt mich gerade auf...
Heute ist der 16.
Äh...
Aha, Dienstagnacht habe ich, okay.
Gut, dass wir darüber gesprochen haben.
Dienstagnacht.
Da gibt es Stonks wieder.
Das Schlimmste, was passieren kann, wenn unser komplettes Lager steht oder sowas, dann haben
wir heute hier richtig Party im Büro.
Einfach softwareseitig zum Beispiel irgendein Problem, was wir nicht beheben können, was
wir die Firma quasi kontaktieren müssen, von dem die Software ist und dann kommt es
zum Stillstand für drei, vier Stunden im Lager.
Heißt, wir können keine Paletten einlagern.
Heißt, wir können nicht produzieren.
Heißt, im Endeffekt kann sogar, kann sogar passieren, dass die Milch weggeschüttet werden
muss.
Ah.
Weil wir einfach nicht so mitmachen können.
Also, das wäre teurer Spaß.
Wovon reden wir da sonst?
Das geht schon im Millionenbereich.
So, gehen wir?
Gehen wir.
Wo sind wir?
Combox 2, oder?
Wir haben einen täglichen Milchumsatz von zwei bis...
Also, was er jetzt so genau macht, hat man noch nicht rausgekriegt, oder?
Wir haben am Tag noch einen Milchumsatz von sechs Millionen Liter.
Es ist tatsächlich so, dass wir 24-7 produzieren.
Das heißt, bei uns kommt 24-7...
Er kommt vielleicht noch.
...gelöscht rein und es wird auch 24-7 verladen.
Hast du wegen der einen Thematik noch in der Lenkung das hinbekommen?
Guten Morgen, Herr Reichspaziert.
Ja.
Ja, du kannst dir gleich direkt zu mir hinsetzen, wenn es...
Wir starten.
Änderung mit Controlling. Das Blöde ist, dass das mittlerweile echt doppeldeutig besetzt ist, dieses Wort. Die könnten damit meinen, okay, wir optimieren Workflows bei den Maschinen, aber man kann mit Workflow optimieren und Controlling auch andere. Das ist halt dumm, wenn du das alles immer gleich nennst.
Wir haben den Prozess ganz normal, wir gehen jetzt einfach mal durch. Wir haben hier ein paar Änderungen quasi einmal durchgeführt. Ich glaube, das meiste haben wir beim letzten Mal schon abgehakt. Ganz stupide erklärt ist ein Workflow, ein Arbeitsablauf, den wir digitalisiert haben.
Okay, dann hört sich das doch eher Richtung Management-Controlling-Kram an und nichts mit Maschinen.
Und auch mit kleinen Hilfen versehen haben, damit es auch wirklich jeder Mitarbeiter, der bei uns auch neu angefangen hat, den sofort eigentlich erstellen kann oder ausführen kann. Änderung Nummer eins war mit Info an PEPO, dass wenn kein Vorlageartikel einmal vorhanden ist, dass da eine Info an...
Boah, da hätte ich ja so keinen Bock drauf, Alter. Das ist ja für mich Horrorvorstellung, wenn ich sowas machen müsste.
So einen Bürokratie-Workflow.
Info-Management. Wobei auf der anderen Seite... Nee, es ist... Ja, was meinen die jetzt? Meinen die jetzt Workflows in Form von Arbeitsabläufen oder meinen die Steuerung von irgendwelchen... So ganz habe ich noch nicht gecheckt, ja.
Die Produktentwicklung rausgeht und wenn einer vorhanden ist, weiß man, gibt es ja schon, dass dann keine Info mehr rausgeht.
Es ist super wichtig, dass bei uns auch auf die kleinsten Zahlen geachtet wird. Also bei mir gab es mal einen kleinen Fall. Ich habe da vergessen, einen Minihaken zu setzen, der fatale Auswirkungen hat.
Das heißt also, der Lagerstaat hat gesagt, nee, die Paletten lagern wir nicht ein. Bitte schickt sie zur Verbrennung quasi, unsere Biogasanlage.
Und das ist dann vorgekommen, dass es eben, ich glaube, über 40 Paletten waren, die direkt weggeschmissen worden sind.
40 Paletten, das sind ein paar Tonnen an Lebensmitteln, die da weggeschmissen worden sind. Das ist halt einfach ein stetiger Lärmprozess, der Job hier.
Das musst du jetzt mal sehen.
Ja, muss ich mal durchtesten, ja.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie so ein fancy Excel.
Manchmal frage ich mich, wenn ich solche Business Enterprise Software sehe, ob ein ordentliches Webinterface da nicht manchmal besser wäre.
Ich meine, ich verstehe, dass das sicherlich sehr schwierig ist, das da alles abzubilden, aber da muss man sich halt ein neues UI überlegen.
Weil ich könnte wetten, das meiste davon ändert sich doch eh nicht. Aber es kommt halt auf ein paar Sachen an.
Sind Tätowierungen ein Grund, weniger Jobaussichten zu haben?
Also ich würde...
Ich würde die Leute unabhängig davon einstellen, ob sie Tattoos haben oder nicht, wäre mir egal.
Ich glaube, dass das mittlerweile weniger ein Problem ist.
Sicherlich hast du immer noch Berufe, wo die da drauf gucken.
Ob sie das offiziell dürfen, weiß ich gar nicht.
Aber es wird bestimmt bei einigen noch ein Kriterium sein, ja.
Das musst du jetzt mal sehen, denke ich.
Ja, musst du das mal durchtesten, ja.
Wirken lassen.
So ein bisschen, so ein Live-Test müssten wir da jetzt einmal fahren.
Das können wir mal machen.
Dann machen wir nächste Woche, übernächste Woche mal einen Testlauf nach dem.
Ja.
Geben allen Bescheid und dann gucken wir mal, was dabei rauskommt.
Ich bin gespannt.
Das wirkte, seriously, das wirkte wie so ein typisches Bullshit-Meeting, was man sich auch hätte sparen können.
Aber klar, ja, da ist das Kamerateam, man muss was zeigen, also vielleicht ist das Ganze auch gestellt.
Gibt's Pizza oder sowas?
Pizza können wir machen, ja.
Dankeschön.
Toss, toss, toss, toss.
Toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss.
In der Käserei erinnert sich noch einer an, wie hieß dieser Battlefield-Server?
Privatkäserei irgendwas?
Kennt das jemand?
Battlefield 3 Käserei.
Wie hieß das Ding?
Da gab's ein Battlefield 3 Server, das hieß irgendwie Privatkäserei.
Ja, das hieß Privatkäserei, sonst was.
Dann gibt's noch einmal weiße Kittel, die brauchen wir in der Produktion.
Natürlich aus Hygienevorschriften, damit wir da auch rein dürfen, weil mit Privatklamotten darf man da nicht rein.
Es passiert jetzt wunderbar was.
Mein Werdegang ist ein bisschen wild gewesen, sag ich mal.
Ich hab erstmal bei uns die Produktion angefangen, weil ich einfach ein bisschen Geld verdienen wollte.
Ich wusste zu der Zeit nicht, was ich arbeiten soll.
Ich war dafür zuständig, dass die verpackten Käsebrote in die Produktion kamen.
Moment, zeig mal her.
Ja.
Genau, Chad, das meinte ich.
Genau, das meinte ich.
Battlefield 3 Server.
Die Privatkäserei an Ries Schumann.
So hieß den Server in Battlefield 3.
Irgendwie war es so einprägsam, das hab ich mir gemerkt.
Die Kartons kommen, palettiert werden und weggeschickt werden.
Je nachdem wie viele Sonntage oder Feiertage du arbeitest, hast du dementsprechend viel Geld bekommen.
Aber im Schnitt würde ich sagen, es war so.
Irgendwo bei 2,7 bis 2,9 in der Spanne.
Warum ich gewechselt bin, ganz einfach.
Ich fand die Arbeit zu eintönig.
Und ich wollte auch nicht mit dem Schichtsystem arbeiten.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Verstehe ich.
Schicht sagt.
Ich habe mir eine Stelle ausgeschrieben im Bereich IT.
In IT wollte ich eigentlich sowieso immer mal reinrutschen und hab mich dann beworben und bin dann Gott sei Dank genommen worden.
Der Sprung von Postbote auf IT, das ist schon 180 Grad Wende, würde ich mal sagen.
Für mich war am Anfang das Thema Programmieren tatsächlich echt so, so wie so Science Fiction.
Also ganz ehrlich, so richtig viel IT habe ich bis jetzt noch nicht gesehen.
Zumindest dann informierst du dich einfach ein bisschen.
Außer ein paar SAP-Forms rumgeklicke oder was das ist.
Dann lernst du ein bisschen was, vielleicht auch über YouTube-Videos oder so was, Tutorials.
Und dann macht das auf einmal Sinn und du kannst dann noch ein paar Monate auf einmal deine eigenen Texte zusammenschreiben.
Servus.
Dann schauen wir mal, das ist das Etikett aktualisiert.
Und da sehen wir quasi, wie das Etikett jetzt ausschaut.
Und das wollen wir natürlich noch eine, ja, ein physisches Etikett.
Haben.
Dazu nehmen wir unseren ganz leichten Karton.
Also mir fehlt in dem Beitrag echt ein bisschen, was er jetzt eigentlich macht.
Ich meine, er wird ja das Etikett nicht erstellt haben oder so.
Was hat er denn jetzt gemacht?
Hat er dann quasi das neue Etikett auf dem USB-Stick mitgebracht?
Oder was ist da eigentlich passiert?
Und führen den einfach mal hier drüber.
Zack.
Und jetzt haben wir hier ein neues Etikett.
Alles was per Anfrage von...
Erkennen wir irgendwas, Chat?
Lass uns mal kurz...
Ihr schaut euch das ja auch immer gerne an hier.
So.
Da erkennen wir...
Wir kennen CSB, das ist ein Ticketsystem.
Habe ich noch nie...
Noch nie gehört, aber CSB-Ticket gibt es ein Ticketsystem, das heißt so.
Ist bestimmt Old School.
Und hässlich.
Warte jetzt.
Okay, Ticketsystem.
Aha, okay.
Soll das sicher übers Internet erreichbar sein, ja?
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Ein Chrome-Icon.
Ansonsten sieht man ehrlich gesagt nicht sonderlich viel.
Alles was per Anfrage von Mitarbeitern reinkommt, wird täglich abgearbeitet.
Also zum Beispiel...
Man erkennt wirklich nicht viel.
Das Notes hier rechts noch?
Nee, gell?
Von den Kacheln hier habe ich erst gedacht, das ist Notes, aber...
Das ist wahrscheinlich doch kein Notes.
Oder frei, ich brauche irgendwo Rahmen frei.
Das sind aktuell bei mir...
FreshService.com
Mir die...
Bestellung an die Milchunion.
Auf einen Ticket.
Die ist noch, die bei uns in der Gruppe drüben liegen.
Schauen wir mal hier rein.
Okay, das Ticketsystem sieht aber brauchbar aus.
Genau, das soll einfach ein bestehender Kreditorkonto, also von der Finanzbuchhaltung ein Konto, damit die was verbuchen können, soll in anderen Mandanten angelegt werden.
So...
Ja, das da rechts, was ist denn das da rechts?
Irgendwas internes, oder?
Auch wenn es ein bisschen aussieht wie Notes, aber es ist wahrscheinlich nicht Notes.
Da gebe ich einmal die Nummer.
Jetzt erkennen wir es, okay.
Okay, kein Plan was, das ist irgendwas internes von denen wahrscheinlich.
Nein.
Zack, das ist quasi einmal unser Konto für den Kreditoren und der soll in den anderen...
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, so als IT-Job geht das für mich nicht, durch ja als Büro-Orga-Job und sowas schon, aber...
IT-mäßig tut sich da jetzt gerade nicht so viel, was man sieht.
Ich nehme ein zweites Programm auf.
Konto ist fertig angelegt und ich kann...
...der Mitarbeiterin schreiben, dass es angelegt ist.
Und Ticket ist quasi gelöst.
Das ging sehr fix.
Das ging fix, ja.
Eine der einfachen Aufgaben hier.
Und jetzt fahre ich quasi einmal alles runter.
Und dann geht es ab in den Feierabend.
Ich verdiene 3.853 Euro brutto im Monat.
Dazu kommt natürlich noch eine Bereitschaftspauschale und gegebenenfalls Zuschläge noch.
Das war in dem letzten Jahr...
Kommst du aber nicht weit mit.
...52 Euro ungefähr an Pauschale.
Alter, da sind ja nur 48.
Das ist ja weniger.
Ja, das ist weniger.
Ich habe tatsächlich sogar noch weniger verdient, wo ich angefangen habe.
Da waren wir bei 2.000 Euro netto ungefähr.
Warum hat es sich für mich gelohnt?
Ja, also alle jetzt natürlich, du arbeitest keine Schicht mehr.
Du arbeitest Montag bis Freitag, hast was für dein Leben.
Und natürlich auch hast du eine beruflichere Herausforderung.
Du hast einen anspruchsvolleren Job.
Das, das, das, das, das.
Das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das.
Vermutlich das.
So, wir haben reinspaziert.
Machen wir ein bisschen Licht an.
Jetzt zeige ich mal kurz meine kleine, aber feine Wohnung.
Da haben wir einmal das Schlafzimmer.
Ich zocke gerne, ja, tatsächlich.
Aktuell zocke ich viel Simracing.
Also Assetto Corsa.
Einmal mit dem Lenker.
Ich kann mal die Computer mal einschalten.
Simracing-Enjoyer.
So.
Wenigstens mal einer mit einem ordentlichen Headset.
Dann starten wir einmal das Spiel.
Tatsächlich fahre ich einen Super-Games Porsche.
Aber aktuell bin ich auf Ferrari umgestiegen.
Nein, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Wenn ja, dann lass auf jeden Fall...
Man hat jetzt ja echt nicht viel gesehen, was er macht, gell?
Also, da war jetzt dieses bei dem Beitrag nicht allzu viel zu holen irgendwo.
Guck mal hier.
Nein, nein, nein, wir gucken jetzt.
Ah ja, doch, doch, wir können tatsächlich hier gucken.
Also, ich weiß jetzt schon von allen Videos, die auf dieser Seite angezeigt werden,
das Letzte, was ich mir angucken werde, ist das hier, Mann.
Dieser ganze YouTuber-Beef, das ist alles so belangloser Krams.
Ey, ich weiß gar nicht, was da immer so abgeht.
Timewaste, genau, Ultra-Timewaste.
Woher kommt man die Sachen...
Ich weiß, das ist Boomer Talk, ja.
Woher kommt man die Sachen auch klären, ohne dass irgendwie 80 Leute...
...darüber erstmal zwei Wochen auf Twitter schreiben und sich dann öffentlich über Videos beefen müssen.
Geht mir auch voll am Arsch vorbei, ey.
Gucken wir uns das mal an.
Guck mal hier, ich gebe hier einfach ein Erdbeere und dann wird mir sofort angezeigt,
wann in den letzten Tagen oder Wochen Erdbeeren auf meinem Bildschirm zu sehen sind.
Oh ja, das will ich unbedingt haben, dass Windows mein Bildschirm aufzeichnet.
Ich kann mir fast nichts Besseres vorstellen.
Nämlich hier in einem YouTube-Video, hier in einer Bildersuche.
Ja, und hier habe ich offenbar das Wort.
Ich kann auch sagen, intime Dinge und dann werden mir intime Dinge angezeigt.
Und obendrein habe ich hier auch so eine Zeitleiste und ich kann hier so durchscrollen, was wann auf meinem Bildschirm zu sehen war.
Windows Recall heißt das Ganze und ist eine neue, sagt der Name schon, Windows-Funktion.
Und ich kann mit ziemlicher Sicherheit sagen, dass das mit Abstand die umstrittenste Windows-Funktion ist seit vielen Jahren.
Mein Kollege Nico findet sogar das Windows Recall.
Das Ende des Personal Computers darstellt.
Das Ende des PCs.
Und es gibt viele konkrete Sicherheitsbedenken.
Wir gucken uns das mal genauer an.
Und statt sich nur auf die Sachen zu verlassen, die Microsoft angekündigt hat.
Ich habe hier ein Windows mit einer Vorab-Version von Recall installiert und ist mehrere Tage im Alltag benutzt.
Und das war ziemlich interessant.
Bleibt dran.
Achso, achso, achso, ganz kurz was in eigener Sache.
Weil wir mehr Videos machen wollen, als ich und Lukas schaffen.
Wir Skriptschreiberinnen und Schreiber.
Also, wenn ihr euch vorstellen könnt, ein zu 3003 passendes Thema zu recherchieren und mundgerecht aufzubereiten und auf...
Schick gerne eine Mail an meine...
Wenn ich das hinkriegen würde, würde ich selbst mal wieder ein Video machen.
...Kollegin Hanna an mondatheise.de.
Und wir zahlen natürlich auch sehr fair.
Und fair bezahlen können wir unter anderem, weil wir jetzt endlich auch 3003 Merch verkaufen.
Wuhuhu.
By the way, warum habe ich noch keine...
...keine einzige YouTube-Werbung heute angezeigt bekommen?
...geht das mit dieser formschönen Hip-Hack oder auch als Bauchtasche bezeichnet.
Super Farbe, super Form.
Habe ich schon oft auf dem Fahrrad verwendet, um da zum Beispiel mein Handy reinzutun im Sommer, wenn man keine Jacke trägt.
Und es gibt hier auch sogar noch eine kleine Geheimtasche, wo zum Beispiel die heiße Kantinenkarte reinpasst.
Und was da auch reinpasst ist...
Habt ihr es gesehen?
...mal wieder unser alter Bekannter, der 50-Cent-China-Chinesen-USB-Stick.
...z.B. die heiße Kantinenkarte reinpasst.
Für 14,90 Euro kann die Tasche dir gehören.
Link zum Shop ist in der Beschreibung.
Liebe Egerin, liebe Internet-Surfer, herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Ja, in diesem Video geht es um Windows, aber unser Sponsor funktioniert auch unter...
...sponsor.
...Linux, MacOS, Android, IOS...
NordVPN, das ist jetzt nett.
So, also jetzt erstmal, was ist hier überhaupt passiert?
Hattest du Werbung mit U-Block, ja?
Auf Microsoft-Konferenz Build wurde ziemlich groß eine neue Windows-Funktion angekündigt.
Windows Recall.
Und bekommen sollen es alle PCs mit dem Copilot Plus-Label als Teil von Windows 11 Version 24H2.
Und angekündigt sind diese Rechner quasi von allen relevanten Herstellern.
Also bislang Acer, Asus, Dell, HP, Medion, Lenovo und Samsung.
Und ab dem 18. Juni, also wenn das Video online geht nächste Woche, sollen die in den Handel kommen.
Dieser Einschub hier entsteht genau in dem Moment, wirklich, als wir das komplett fertige Video gerade zu YouTube hochladen wollten.
Und wir dann aber gesehen haben, dass Microsoft Recall jetzt nochmal weiter verschoben hat.
Und gesagt hat, zum 18. Juni, wenn die Copilot Plus-PCs rauskommen, wird Recall noch nicht standardmäßig in Windows...
Wie gesagt, das ist alles Salami-Taktik. Sobald das da ist, wird es eingeschaltet.
...integriert sein.
Das wird jetzt erstmal wieder nur so ein Insider-Feature.
Sie wollen da also noch weiter dran rumbasteln.
Wir haben uns aber entschieden, das Video trotzdem zu veröffentlichen.
Einfach nur, um euch zumindest mal die Grundfunktionalität von Recall zu zeigen.
Die wird ja voraussichtlich in irgendeiner Form in Windows irgendwann integriert sein.
Die hier in dem Video beschriebenen Sicherheitsmängel sind dann aber hoffentlich raus.
Also das bitte im Hintergrund, wenn ihr euch das Video anguckt.
Viel Spaß.
Bei Rechnern ohne Copilot Plus-Label.
Mit dem Update 24H2 bekommen, wird die Funktion offenbar noch nicht aktiv sein.
Und alle diese Copilot Plus-PCs haben einen KI-Beschleuniger eingebaut, also eine NPU, Neural Processing Unit.
Ja, und damit man auch irgendwie zeigen kann, dass die NPU-Rechner irgendwas anders können als normale,
hat man sich halt offenbar dieses Windows Recall als Exklusivfunktion ausgedacht.
Also soweit so gut.
Der Witz ist aber nun, dass wir Recall auf einem anderthalb Jahre alten Mini-PC testen konnten.
Und zwar auf dem Windows Dev Kit.
Der Dev Kit 2023 mit Qualcomm Snapdragon 8CX Gen 3.
Einem im Vergleich zu den kommenden Rechnern wohl deutlich langsameren Gerät.
Und Recall funktionierte trotzdem problemlos.
Also auch mein Dev Kit hat angeblich so eine NPU.
Die NPU wird aber in der von mir getesteten Windows-Version irgendwo angezeigt.
Ja, aber du kannst davon ausgehen, das ist alles Salami-Taktik.
Früher oder später ist das dabei und früher oder später ist das dann nicht mehr Opt-In, sondern Opt-Out.
Also...
Selbst wenn es standardmäßig Opt-In ist, finde ich so eine Funktion hat nichts in Windows zu suchen.
Wenn es eine Zusatzsoftware ist, die man sich installieren kann, ja, okay.
Däte-Manager, wo sie eigentlich sein sollte.
Okay, naja, wollen wir mal abwarten.
Ich möchte ehrlich gesagt, dass mein Windows gar keine Funktion standardmäßig mitbringt,
um alle Minuten oder meinen Desktop aufzuzeichnen und zu Microsoft zu checken.
Die neuen Co-Pilot Plus Rechner kommen zwar schon nächste Woche,
aber das entsprechende Windows ist offenbar noch nicht fertig.
Alles sehr mit heißer Nadel gestrickt.
Ich habe für dieses Video die Vorab-Version von Windows 11 24H2 mit diesem Build hier verwendet.
Das ist vom 7. Juni 2024.
Gut, zum 18. Juni, also zur Veröffentlichung der Co-Pilot Plus PCs, ist jetzt nicht mehr so viel Zeit,
aber es können sich da natürlich noch Dinge ändern.
Microsoft hat ja auch schon Änderungen angekündigt, dazu später mehr.
Deshalb, meine Erfahrungen hier sind natürlich nur eine Momentaufnahme, um überhaupt generell...
Ich traue denen nicht, wenn die sagen, dass das reine OK läuft.
... zu verstehen, wie dieses Windows-Recall funktioniert, was da auf uns zukommt.
Bis zur finalen Version kann sich da natürlich noch was ändern.
So, aber wie funktioniert das jetzt genau mit dem Recall?
Das ist, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen der Reiz.
Es ist super einfach das Verstehen, auch nicht computeraffine Leute.
Unten in der Taskleiste gibt es da nun dieses Symbol, hinter dem sich Recall verbirgt,
oder auf Deutsch übersetzt mit Abruf.
Also das glaube ich auf keinen Fall, dass das so bleibt.
Abruf?
Abruf!
Hä, hast du auch schon das neue Windows mit Abruf?
Ja, ich habe auch das neue Windows mit Abruf!
Ja, auf jeden Fall, wenn man dann auf Abruf öffnen klickt, dann kommt das.
Und hier oben kann ich mich dann durch diesen...
Das ist, das ist, das ist typische Microsoft-Übersetzung.
Genauso wie der Projekt-Mappen-Verwaltungs-Konfigurationsassistent oder sowas.
Zeitstrahl hier bewegen.
Unten sehe ich dann die Screenshots und hier oben steht die Uhrzeit.
Ich kann mir also quasi mein Leben, also,
meinen Computeraltag, wie in so einem Video angucken und da so rum skippen.
Klicke ich da länger drauf, dann wird der Zeitstrahl hier oben größer und dann kann
ich mich dann noch mal feiner abgestuft durchhangeln.
Hier habe ich zum Beispiel die Apple WWDC Keynote angeguckt und hier habe ich das Skript
für dieses Video hier geschrieben.
Microsoft sagt, dass alle fünf Sekunden so ein Screenshot gemacht wird, also zumindest
wenn sich der Bildschirminhalt verändert.
Bei meinen Tests hier, also auch wenn ich ein Video habe laufen lassen.
Also, wenn sich der Bildschirminhalt verändert.
Und dann bin ich auf maximal vier Screenshots in der Minute gekommen, also maximal alle
15 Sekunden.
Und auch auffällig ist, dass es manchmal so Erinnerungslücken gibt.
Hier hatte ich die ganze Nacht YouTube Videos laufen und ja, die Aufzeichnung stoppt um
23.36 Uhr und beginnt erst wieder um 7.56 Uhr.
An den Energieeinschränkungen liegt das nicht.
Der Rechner ist so eingestellt, dass er sich nie ausschaltet und nie in den Energiesparmodus
schaltet.
Bei den fehlenden Mausbewegungen sollte es eigentlich auch nicht liegen, weil solche
mehrstündigen YouTube Video Sessions ohne Mausbewegung wurden da schon aufgezeichnet,
also an denen ich da nicht am PC gesessen habe.
Naja, eventuell liegt das daran, dass die Hardware hier noch nicht so leistungsfähig
ist wie die künftigen Co-Pilot Plus PCs oder halt weil die Software noch nicht fertig ist.
Aber es werden auf jeden Fall auch so viele viele Screenshots erzeugt und die kann man
– und jetzt wird es interessant – durchsuchen.
Weil Windows lässt über jeden Screenshot ein lokales KI-Modell laufen.
Und das ist das, was wir hier sehen.
Was nicht nur OCR-mäßig Texte erkennt, sondern auch Bilder.
Stichwort Multimodalität.
Das können Sprachmodelle ja jetzt häufiger, dass die nicht nur Text verstehen, sondern
auch Bilder und künftig auch Töne und Gespräche und Musik und alles.
Das heißt, wenn ich mich so vage erinnere, dass…
Überlegt euch…
Ja, sowas ähnliches habe ich auch gehört.
Überlegt euch mal, ihr fangt euch irgendeine Malware ein auf dem Rechner.
Da kann er nicht mehr.
Die kann nicht nur eure aktuellen Browser-Sessions hijacken, sondern, der kann dann auch gucken,
ob ihr gestern um 16 Uhr Porn geguckt habt und euch damit erpressen.
Wird eine ganz tolle Idee, oder?
Wenn ich so ein tolles Fahrrad gesehen habe oder halt eine Erdbeere, dann tippe ich das
hier ein und dann finde ich, wenn alles gut geht, diesen Screenshot hier.
Man kann dann auch direkt in die Software springen, die da lief.
Die Software steht da auch immer unten.
Oder die URL.
Hier kann ich dann auch sogar direkt in das Dokument reinspringen.
Ja, Screenshots vom KeePass.
Ich habe nämlich jetzt mal das Wort Gepardenforelle getippt.
Und wenn ich das dann später in Recall suche,
dann kann ich mit einem Klick mich hier wieder in das Dokument katapultieren.
Und natürlich, das kann alles sinnvoll sein.
Ganz ehrlich, ich finde das vom Ansatz her gar nicht so schlecht.
Gerade für Leute wie mich, die total unorganisiert sind, was solche Sachen angeht.
Und ich finde da die Sachen immer nicht.
Obwohl ich weiß, ich habe es vor zwei Tagen mal gesehen.
Ja, aber wenn ich sowas verwenden würde,
dann nur Open Source und nur rein lokal selbst bei mir am Start.
Für Dateien durchsuchen braucht man keine KI.
Ob du es jetzt KI nennst oder wie auch immer.
Aber so eine Sache mit Texterkennung in Bildern und sowas,
da reicht es mit einer einfachen...
Textsuche in Dateien ja nicht mehr aus.
Zum Beispiel passiert in meinem Arbeitsleben sehr viel über Textnachrichten.
Und ich habe mir dann irgendwie gemerkt, ich habe mit Person XY über YX getextet.
Aber ich weiß dann manchmal nicht mehr, ob das per Signal, WhatsApp, Mail oder Teams war.
Und so kann ich dann einfach nach einem Stichwort des Gesprächs suchen.
Und zack, habe ich das Gespräch hier.
Thema Speicherplatz übrigens.
Ungefähr drei Arbeitstage haben bei mir knapp 700 Megabyte Daten erzeugt.
Da kommt man in eine Mode.
Also auf ganz grob sieben Gigabyte.
Ja, das läppert sich also.
Man kann aber auch einstellen, ab wann die alten Sachen wieder gelöscht werden.
Also ab 25, 50 oder 75 Gigabyte.
Dann wird dann das alte gelöscht, damit neues erzeugt werden kann.
Ich habe übrigens auch mal Erwachsenen Unterhaltung laufen lassen.
Und ja, klar, das wurde natürlich auch alles mitgeschnitten.
Und es gibt da zwar offenbar so einen puritanischen USA-Filter,
so dass man bestimmte Wörter nicht suchen kann, zum Beispiel nude.
Aber wenn ich nackt suche,
ja, dann kommen mir die ganzen Screenshots mit den entsprechenden Videos
und aber auch Screenshots, die gar nichts mit Nacktheit zu tun haben.
Keine Ahnung.
So, und ich denke, ich muss euch jetzt gar nicht mehr genau sagen,
wo da eventuell auch Probleme liegen bei Windows Recall.
Denn klar, das sind halt wirklich Daten, nach denen sich viele Leute die Finger lecken,
weil man da halt wirklich alles drauf sehen kann, was Leute an ihren PCs machen.
Und alles an einem Ort.
Also, was weiß ich, irgendwelche Excel-Tabellen mit Geschäftsgeheimnissen,
Banking-Informationen, kompromittierende Fotos.
Wenn man Zugriff auf die Recall-Daten hat, dann kriegt man das alles auf dem Silbertablett geliefert.
Schön durchsuchbar.
Und das gilt jetzt nicht nur für Hacker, Geheimdienste, Excel-Lover,
sondern auch für Arbeitgeber.
Weil, ja klar, man sieht dann zum Beispiel genau, was die Leute im Homeoffice so machen.
Oder vielleicht auch für Microsoft.
Naja, wenn man einen Rechner verwendet von...
Ja, dann...
Selbst, weil man ja aus diesen Daten sehr sicher,
ein ziemlich gutes KI-Modell machen kann,
was dann vielleicht irgendwann mal das beherrscht, was Computerarbeiter alles können.
Ich sage damit nicht, dass diese Daten standardmäßig von irgendjemandem ausgewertet werden,
sondern erstmal nur, dass sie hochgradig spannend für viele Menschen und Instanzen sind.
Und deshalb sehr gut abgesichert werden müssen.
Und genau das passiert bei der von mir hier getesteten Variante nicht.
Sobald man Zugriff auf den Rechner hat mit irgendeinem Windows-Admin-Zugang,
dann kann man die Recall-Screenshots in jedem anderen Windows-Admin-Account auch anschauen.
Man muss nur ins Users-Verzeichnis gehen, dann den Usernamen auswählen
und dann fragt Windows einmal nach, ob man wirklich Zugriff haben will.
Klickt man dann auf Ja, dann hangelt man sich auf AppData, Local Core IP-Adform .00 slash UKP
und da findet man dann ganz viele Bilddateien.
Das sind einfach JPEGs, unverschlüsselt.
Die sind halt nur nicht als JPEGs benannt, also die kann man einfach umbenennen.
Und dann...
Dann kann man sich die angucken.
Und es gibt auch noch eine SQLite-Datenbank und ja, da werden unter anderem
die in den Screenshots erkannten Texte eingetragen, aber auch ganz viele Metadaten.
Da sieht man mal wieder, Microsoft kocht da halt auch nur mit Wasser, ne?
Wie lange genau welches Programmfenster im Vordergrund war und so weiter und so weiter.
Also auch perfekte Ausspionier-Daten.
Will man das alles komfortabel auslesen, kann man zum Beispiel einfach das Python-Script
Total Recall von Alexander Hagener von GitHub herunterladen.
Und ausführen.
Zack, da wird dann die Datenbank schön in eine Datei geschrieben und die Screenshots richtig benannt.
Sehr komfortabel.
Aber erstmal nochmal für euch zur Sicherheit.
Die Daten gehen nicht in die Cloud.
Das heißt, die Text- und Bilderkennung, die findet lokal auf der eigenen Hardware statt.
Würde das in die Cloud gehen, ja, dann wäre das wirklich eine totale Katastrophe.
Aber so ist es halt auch auf jeden Fall gefährlich, weil man muss ja erstmal Microsoft vertrauen,
dass die mit den Daten vernünftig umgehen.
Aber vor allem schafft man halt für alle Leute...
Dem einen letzten Unternehmen, den ich...
...böses...
...den ich da vertrauen würde bei Microsoft...
...wollen, eine super gute Möglichkeit, ohne viel Aufwand, an alle Daten auf einem Haufen zu erbeuten.
Die Datenbank ist dann quasi das Inhaltsverzeichnis.
Wir fanden übrigens keine Indikation, dass in der Datenbank Dinge gespeichert werden,
die man nicht auf dem Bildschirm sehen konnte.
Also zum Beispiel Passwörter.
Klickt man aber bei Passworteingaben auf das Anzeigen-Bull,
ja, dann stecken natürlich auch Passwörter in den Screenshots und in der Datenbank.
All das sehen natürlich viele Leute kritisch.
Auch ich, weil es gibt ja den Computersignal.
Security-Spruch, wo ein Trog steht, da kommen die Schweine.
Also das ist einfach hochgradig gefährlich.
Das ist tatsächlich ein guter, passender Spruch, ja.
Das ist auch so eines der Dinge, wo ich mich immer frage,
warum die Leute tatsächlich Online-Passwort-Manager benutzen
oder ihre Sachen hochladen, die man nicht notwendigerweise ins Internet stellen müsste.
Weil ja, selbst wenn die nach heutigen Maßstäben alle ganz toll und sicher sind,
sobald die Daten erstmal im Internet sind oder sobald man die erstmal aus der Hand gegeben hat,
als eine Kopie davon, dann sind die erstmal in den Händen auch von unter anderem anderen Leuten.
Man weiß nicht, wie es in 15 Jahren aussieht.
Man weiß auch nicht, was damit in Zukunft noch passiert.
Die einfachste Sache zu vermeiden ist, echt nur das ins Internet stellen oder hochladen irgendwo,
was unbedingt sein muss.
Und man muss nicht sein ganzes Leben irgendwo hin hochpumpen,
sondern nur das, was man auch wirklich mobil braucht.
Dann hast du ganz viele Probleme gar nicht.
Weil was nicht da ist, damit kann auch nichts passieren.
Offen auf einem Rechner zu haben.
Da habe ich ja schon am Anfang gesagt, dass mein Kollege Nico findet,
dass es das Ende des Personal Computers ist,
weil ein Rechner mit Recall-Daten eben kein persönliches, kein privates Ding mehr ist,
sondern ein Gerät, das mich 24-7 überwacht und womöglich gegen mich verwendet werden kann.
Ja, und weil es auch noch sehr viele andere Leute außer Nico kritisiert haben,
hat Microsoft kurz vor Redaktionsschluss dieses Videos,
eingelenkt.
Microsoft sagt, Recall soll keine standardmäßig aktivierte Funktion mehr sein.
Ich finde nicht, dass...
Ich würde da sogar noch einen Schritt weiter gehen.
Ich bin der Meinung, das sollte gar kein Bestandteil von Windows sein,
egal ob Opt-in oder Opt-out.
Ich meine, besser, dass es Opt-in ist, ja, keine Frage.
Aber das ist alles nur Salami-Taktik.
So was kann eine Zusatzsoftware sein, ja, aber kein Windows-Bestandteil.
Ursprünglich so geplant.
Also es ist jetzt erst mal Opt-in.
Überlegt euch mal.
Man muss das manuell.
Da hast du quasi...
Das ist eine Spy-Funktion, die nicht detektbar ist.
Du fängst dir irgendwas ein, das Ding aktiviert Recall,
schaltet sich wieder aus.
Nichts wird das als ungewollt erkennen,
weil es ist ja offizielles Windows-Recall.
Also...
...einschalten.
Und außerdem sollen Screenshots...
Kannst du kurz Salami-Taktik erklären.
Damit ist gemeint, dass wenn du was einführen möchtest,
was die Leute nicht wollen,
dann machst du das inklusive.
In kleinen Häppchen.
Das ist mit Salami-Taktik gemeint.
Ja?
Du führst...
Du führst bei...
Siehst du jetzt bei Recall, ja?
Ja, kein für Gachi-Baiwack.
War ja klar.
Da ist es gleich irgendwie sowas.
Komm, ne?
Nimm das doch mal als Beispiel von Recall.
Es wird vorgestellt, die Leute finden es scheiße.
Dann sagt Microsoft, ach, ist doch gar nicht so schlimm.
Wir bringen es standardmäßig nur auf ARM-CPUs.
Ach, ähm...
Wir installieren es nicht vor.
Ach, es kommt mit einem Update mit, aber ist standardmäßig auch nicht so schlimm.
Es kommt mit einem Update mit, aber ist standardmäßig auch nicht so schlimm.
Und dann geht das immer so weiter.
Immer in so kleinen Schritten.
Immer bis zu dieser Linie, wo die Leute sagen,
Ah, jetzt habe ich da keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Und ein paar Monate später wird es wieder versucht, ein Stückchen weiter...
Das heißt, sobald sowas mal da ist, sobald man quasi...
Wie kann man sagen?
So einen Fuß in der Tür hat, kommt das früher oder später.
Das Salami-Taktik ist gang und gäbe in ganz vielen Bereichen.
Jedes Mal, wenn es um Sachen geht,
auf die die Leute eigentlich keinen Bock haben, aber irgendjemanden durchdrücken möchte,
ja, das ist auch schlecht, ja.
Es muss Windows Hello aktiv sein, also das Einloggen über Gesichtserkennung,
Fingerabdruck oder Pin.
Und außerdem soll es eine sogenannte Proof of Presence geben.
Also eine, also ein Anwesenheits-Check.
Das hat Microsoft noch nicht so detailliert erörtert.
Das würde ich alles schon mal als positiv bewerten.
Aber man muss das natürlich weiter im Auge behalten.
Also es wäre zum Beispiel denkbar, dass die Funktion in Zukunft durch irgendein Update
einfach eingeschaltet wird, ohne dass man das mitbekommt.
Muss man mal gucken. Mein Fazit.
Also ganz klar, Windows Recall ist auf jeden Fall hochgradig gefährlich.
Einfach weil das Daten produziert, die sehr, sehr, sehr ins Persönliche gehen.
Ich kann nach meinem Praxistest sagen, dass sich das für mich unangenehm angefühlt hat.
Ich erkläre euch jetzt mal, was genau in dem Fall passiert.
Die Leute, die kündigen das an
und die Leute sagen Oh Scheiße, das will ich nicht so.
Dann sagt Microsoft Ach, wir führen das ein.
Aber es ist standardmäßig aus und dann sagen die Leute
Ah gut, atmen auf, dann betrifft mich das doch gar nicht.
Nach zwei Jahren kommt ein Update,
wo das Sneaky ganz einfach eingeschaltet wird, standardmäßig
und keiner hat es mir richtig auf dem Schirm und schon ist am Start.
Und der Aufschrei ist bei weitem nicht so groß.
Mit dieser Funktion und diese KI permanent über die Schulter schaut
und alles auswertet, was ich am Rechner mache, aber auch ganz klar ist Praktisch ist das schon.
Und komfortabel ist das auch.
Ich denke, wir kennen das alle, dass wir irgendwas suchen,
was wir gesehen, besprochen, geschrieben haben und uns nicht mehr genau erinnern,
in welchem Kontext das war.
Auch gerade für Leute, deren Gehirn eher visuell funktioniert als mit Sprache.
Die können dann halt einfach nach Bildern suchen.
Aber man muss halt für sich entscheiden, ob der Gewinn an Komfort
durch Recall höher zu bewerten ist als der potenzielle Verlust an Privatsphäre.
Für mich kann ich sagen, dass ich diese Funktion nur dann einschalten würde,
wenn ich mir absolut, absolut.
Sicher wäre, dass die Daten sehr gut geschützt sind
und ich sehr genau einstellen kann, wann nicht mitgeschnitten wird.
In der von mir ausprobierten Version kann ich sagen,
dass bestimmte Programme gar nicht recalled werden sollen oder auch einzelne Websites nicht.
Ich muss aber auch sagen, dass das für mich jetzt erst mal nicht ausreichend ist,
weil Dinge, bei denen ich nicht beobachtet werden will.
Das ist zum Beispiel private Kommunikation.
Die findet oft in der gleichen Software statt, wie auch berufliche Kommunikation stattfindet.
Die will ich ja womöglich im Suchindex haben.
Ja, ich bin mir gespannt.
Wie das weitergeht, ist womöglich Recall jetzt wirklich der Stein,
der das Fass zum Überlaufen bringt und die Leute zu Linux oder Mac führt?
Oder werden die Co-Pilot Plus-PCs ein Riesenerfolg wegen Recall?
Nee, das nicht.
Gerne in die Kommentare schreiben.
Ich denke, das ist so ein Ding, was wieder im Sande verlaufen wird.
Das Microsoft hat mal wieder versucht.
... jetzt schon verwenden kann.
Jo, hier ist einmal Keno aus der Zukunft mit schlechtem Ton und schlechtem Licht.
Ich hatte das Tutorial gerade schon fertig und dann gesehen,
dass Microsoft tatsächlich die ISO nicht mehr online hat.
Also an der Stelle, an der ich die runtergeladen habe, ist die nicht mehr.
Hat ja auch seine Gründe.
Ist ja auch sinnvoll von Microsoft, weil, wie wir im Video gezeigt haben,
das Ding gar nicht verschlüsselt.
Deswegen, wenn ihr es unbedingt testen wollt, dann wartet auf die finale Version
oder benutzt gleich Open Recall.
Die Leute vergessen nichts.
Die Leute vergessen nach zwei Tagen schon, wenn was gewesen ist.
Aber ja, oder ihr benutzt es gar nicht, ist auch eine gute Variante.
Tschüss.
See you.
Wollten wir noch das hier angucken?
Ruby on Rails.
FireShip hat ein neues Video über Ruby.
Nicht, dass ich irgendwie wieder vor hätte, mal was in Ruby on Rails zu machen.
Aber FireShip macht immer gute Videos.
Was haben wir hier?
The Linux Experiment.
Have you tried Linux, perhaps?
Ja, ist es.
Das ist das, ähm, genau.
Dragon Roost Island.
Ist es.
Dann gucken wir uns doch mal an, was FireShip über Ruby on Rails zu erzählen hat.
Leider, muss man ja echt sagen, ist Ruby on Rails nicht mehr so im Hype wie früher.
Ich find's ein bisschen doof.
Aus zwei Gründen.
Und zwar, das erste, Ruby on Rails, war ein wirklich nicest Framework.
Von der Usability her.
Und das nächste ist, ich mag Ruby als Programmiersprache.
Ich hab auch viel in Ruby gemacht, was nichts mit Rails zu tun hat.
Leider ist Ruby überhaupt nicht mehr angesagt.
Ruby on Rails.
A full-stack MVC-Web-Framework, famous for powering some of the most successful Internet Startups.
Chatge?
HiIQ-Frage?
Was ist mit MVC gemeint?
Kleiner IQ-Check des Chats.
Jetzt ohne zu googeln.
Googeln kann ich auch.
Ich mein, ich weiß es auch aus dem Kopf.
Model-View-Controller, korrekt.
Der Chat weiß Bescheid.
Moin Max, wie läuft der Sport?
Richtig nice.
Nächstes Wochenende, wenn gutes Wetter ist, 22 Kilometer.
Gestern noch mal Probe gerannt.
Knapp 14 oder 13,5.
Schneller als ich die 22 rennen will.
Ja, Model-View-Controller.
Chat weiß Bescheid.
...of the last 20 years.
It was created in 2004 by David Hanemeyer Hansen.
Den keiner richtig aussprechen kann, ja.
...to give developers a way to build large-scale web applications quickly with the Ruby programming language.
Kraftsport, ey.
It exploded in popularity among the Silicon Valley tech-bro scene and helped launch unicorn startups like Airbnb, Shopify and GitHub.
Twitter war ursprünglich auch mal ne Ruby on Rails Anwendung.
GitLab auch.
GitLab ist es, glaube ich, immer noch.
Twitter nicht mehr. Twitter ist mittlerweile auf Java-Basis, soweit ich weiß.
...to name a few.
Its underlying architecture is based on the Model-View-Controller-Pattern.
A model contains the business logic for your database.
Rails has a built-in ORM called ActiveRecord that can easily model relationships in a SQL database.
On the other end we have the view for presentation logic, which includes a mix of HTML, CSS and embedded Ruby, which displays...
Das ist halt heute...
Das ist halt heute nicht mehr so angesagt.
Das ist quasi so reines Server-Side-Rendering mit ERB-Templates.
Ich finde übrigens ERB-Templates auch immer noch heute eines der angenehmsten Template-Languages überhaupt.
Weil es halt auch Ruby ist, ja.
Aber reines Server-Side-Rendering ist halt heute nicht mehr angesagt.
...dynamic data queried from the backend.
This data is made available by the controller, which sits in the middle.
It takes the incoming HTTP request from the user, fetches data from the model and finally responds with HTML or JSON.
This pattern actually predates the web itself...
Ich habe gerade was getrunken.
...extremely easy to implement by following a highly opinionated and controversial doctrine,
which includes nine commandments like convention over configuration and exalt beautiful code.
Let's build a full-stack application right now by installing Ruby, Rails and SQLite.
Now run the Rails new command to scaffold out a new project.
From here you'll notice a gem file to install...
Da muss man jetzt mal was sagen. Heute ist das ja normal.
Heute hast du gerade in der JavaScript-Welt, bringt so gut wie jedes Tool seine eigene Command-Side...
...ehm, nicht Command-Side, äh, Command-Line-Tools mit, ja?
Du kannst heute, wenn du eine neue Svelte-Kit-Anwendung erstellen willst, machst du npx, äh, npx new Svelte...
Die Channel Points, die sind immer noch da.
Hier, da sind sie doch.
Die sind ganz normal da.
Was, die sind weg?
Twitter macht wieder... Aha.
Das ist, glaube ich, das Kleine.
Da muss man erst runterscrollen irgendwie.
Ja, was wollte ich sagen?
Das, das war damals was Neues.
Ja, wie gesagt, heute bringt jedes Tool irgendwelche Command-Line-Hilfen mit, um ein neues Projekt zu erstellen und so was.
Das war damals nicht so.
Ruby on Rails war eines der ersten, die das gemacht haben.
Und das war halt für viele super Erleichterung, ja?
Du sagst Rails new, da hast du Rails migrate und alles mögliche.
Du kriegst halt die Sachen schnell so vom, vom Startfeld so, ja?
Now run the Rails new command to scaffold out a new project.
From here you'll notice a gemfile to install dependencies in Ruby, a rakefile, which is like a makefile...
Gemfile ist quasi Package JSON, wenn man so will, ja.
Und rake ist quasi das Gegenstück, ja gut, npm run, so nach dem Motto.
... to run a task, but the bulk of your code will be written in the app directory.
In addition to models, views and controllers, you'll also notice mailers for transactional tasks.
E-mail, jobs for background work and channels for realtime connections via websockets.
And we have a JavaScript directory configured with Hotwire, allowing you to build a highly interactive frontend without the unnecessary complexity of a JavaScript component framework.
Rails also has an extremely powerful CLI.
Generate will build your models, views and controllers or do everything all at once with Scaffold.
We give our model a name, which is plural by convention, then provide some fields and types we might use in the database.
This command creates a bunch of files.
But let's go ahead and run rake to migrate the database.
Then rail server to run it locally.
Congratulations, you just built a piece of crud.
A full stack app that can create, read, update...
Ja, Ruby ist nicht mehr so angesagt. Rails auch nicht.
... your database model in the browser.
How did we do that so fast?
At first, the routes.rb file mapped a set of URLs to our controller.
Automagically created by this resources method.
When a user navigates to one of those routes, it triggers a controller action.
Like index, we'll fetch all the records from the database by calling...
Active record, also das ist der... der...
ORM-Mapper von Ruby on Rails.
Ist echt angenehm zu benutzen. Also, Rails hat was.
... the all method, which is provided automatically by the model.
We could also perform data validations here and do joins with other models.
Now the controller created an instance variable, which we can access directly in the html.embedded-ruby file.
Here we have each row in the database as a Ruby object, which we can loop over with each to display it in the front-end UI.
This has been Rails in 100 seconds.
But if you really want to learn how to build cool web apps, it's far more important to learn how to problem-solve like a programmer.
You can start making that happen for free thanks to this video's sponsor, Brilliant.
Web frameworks come and go, but problem-solving is a skill that you keep forever.
Brilliance Platform will introduce you to essential programming concepts, but most importantly, the hands-on exercises will develop your brain to...
... high IQ training.
Eigentlich schade, dass Rails so an Bedeutung verloren gehabt hat.
Und dadurch Ruby auch.
Ich mochte das.
Und ich würde auch heute noch was in Ruby programmieren, aber das ist so...
... un...
... negativ hyped gerade.
Ne, hab ich noch nicht.
Okay, was bin ich hier sehend? Was ist das?
Arch, by the way.
Yeah.
I've been using Windows for most of my life.
And a few years ago I've fallen victim to MacOS.
But Linux?
I've never dared to enter that garden.
Who knows what deep, exotic creatures lie beneath on the other side.
So after reading just a few friendly comments trying to convert me into a Linux user, I decided, why not?
Why shouldn't I try it?
Okay, also ist das ein Linux-Noob versucht sich an Linux, da mal gucken.
And after watching a few tutorials, I decided it was time to install it for the first time.
Now this screen might not seem like I'm doing much here, but actually at this very moment I was completely nuking my entire hard drive.
Reducing it to atoms, completely erasing it.
I didn't realize this until I switched...
Da kommt aber eigentlich noch ne Abfrage, ne?
... back to Windows.
Oh bugger.
But now I've built a new PC with an AMD graphics card, which apparently is good for Linux,
so I'm going to start this over.
Now during this whole process, there was one thought that kept bouncing inside my head.
What can you even do with Linux, the Penguin Operating System?
Or should I say, what ca-
Zumindest schon mal keine Spiele mit Anti-Cheat spielen.
Can't you do?
Übrigens, wie ist das eigentlich jetzt?
Es gibt ja gerade die Spiele von Valve und auch CSGO und so, die gehen ja unter Linux.
Wie sieht's denn eigentlich mit CS2 aus?
Läuft das unter Linux?
Würde mal von ausgehen.
Ja?
VAC funktioniert nicht?
Das heißt, du kannst kein ranked spielen?
Oder wie, wenn VAC nicht geht?
VAC läuft?
Ja was jetzt?
Okay.
Also, es ist mittlerweile echt erstaunlich, wie viel gut funktioniert.
Leider sind wir noch ein bisschen davon entfernt, dass das so quasi Steam auf, Game kaufen, installieren, loslegen ist unter Linux.
Aber es ist kein Vergleich.
Gleich zu vor ein paar Jahren.
Ich mein, ich hab das ja alles live beobachtet seit 2007.
Da lief ja fast nix.
Mittlerweile, was Games angeht, ist ziemlich gut.
Aber man kann's halt immer noch nicht sagen, so rundum glücklich.
Du kannst immer noch nicht sagen, okay, ah ja, mir egal, ich spiel was ich will und es geht einfach.
Das ist halt nicht.
Gerade wenn du Sachen spielen willst, wie beispielsweise Rainbow Six Siege oder sowas.
Vergiss es halt.
Aber das liegt halt an Anti-Cheat.
Nicht so sehr an den Games.
Mit Linux.
No, but seriously.
When you switch from Windows to Mac, you give up some software that only exists on Windows, gaming and some bloatware in return for nice hardware and software integration, but a more controlled...
Hast du Dualboot oder nur Windows?
Ich hab weder noch.
Ich hab Windows und Linux parallel am Start, guck mal hier.
Brauch kein Dualboot.
Dualboot is outdated, overrated, jebaited.
Aber das ist ganz...
Das sieht jetzt komplizierter aus als es ist.
Windows auf dem Host und das hier ist eigentlich nur eine VM.
Ja, ja, das ist eine VM im Fullscreen.
Aber was ich unter Linux mache...
Oh, irgendwie...
Meine VM hat gerade so ein paar kleine Probleme.
Ist meine VM gerade abgeschissen oder was?
Sieht so aus.
Oh weh.
Crip.
Arch, by the way.
Startet es sich automatisch, wenn du dein PC neu startest?
Nee.
Muss es ja aber auch nicht.
Warum nicht WSL?
Hauptsächlich wegen Kleinigkeiten, die mich nerven.
Und ich hab halt gerne I3 als Oberfläche.
Passwort Max? Nee.
Passwort ist 123456.
LEAKT!
...old, yet seamless, consistent operating system that works wonderfully within its ecosystem.
And so what do you give up when you switch to Linux and what do you get in...
Okay, okay.
Animations hängt davon ab, was ich benutze.
So, eher nicht so nice.
Price, natürlich super, kostet nix.
Beginner-Friendly, kommt ein bisschen drauf an.
Beginner-Friendly für...
Man will eigentlich nur seinen Browser aufmachen und da drin ein bisschen rumklicken.
Easy as fuck unter Linux.
Ja, gerade mit sowas wie Linux Mint oder so.
Ansonsten will er auch ein bisschen was advanceres machen.
Dann gar nicht.
Hardwarekompatibilität ist mittlerweile echt nicht verkehrt.
Gerade mit Arch Linux, weil man immer einen neuen Kernel am Start hat.
Ist die echt ganz okay.
Ich würde vielleicht nicht sagen 5 Sterne wie bei Windows.
Aber...
Nur nach 5, also das...
Zu 99% ist das out of the box funktioniert der Kram mittlerweile unter Linux.
Wo es Probleme gibt, sind Grafikkarten.
Ja, also würde ich Linux tatsächlich auch, gerade im Hinblick auf Grafikkarten...
Maximal...
Aber dafür funktioniert vieles andere und auch exotische Sachen.
Ja, beispielsweise wenn du einen Microphone hast.
Wenn du einen Microcontroller anschließt.
Der USB zu Serial Converter.
Der braucht einen extra Treiber unter Windows.
Unter Linux, out of the box.
Also ich würde Linux tatsächlich auch 4 geben.
Vielleicht 3,5.
Aber sagen wir mal 4 mittlerweile.
Viel viel besser geworden im Vergleich zu früher.
Ökosystem drum herum.
Das ist jetzt die Frage, wie das gemeint ist.
Also es gibt sicherlich bei weitem nicht so viel Software für Linux.
Offiziell.
Wie für Windows.
Aber das Ökosystem...
Aber das Ökosystem an sich...
Mit Package Manager und allem...
Ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Also wenn man mal rein von Verfügbarkeit und Menge der Software angeht, ist...
Linux jetzt vielleicht irgendwo in der Mitte.
Bloatware hast du gar nichts.
Gaming würde ich sagen...
3,5 Sterne mittlerweile.
Ach hier kommt Available Software.
Ja, Available Software gebe ich Linux tatsächlich auch 4 Sterne.
Du hast zwar...
Viele Sachen nichts, was in Richtung Audio, Video und Editing und sowas angeht.
Wobei es da auch immer besser wird.
Dafür hast du unter Linux viele andere Sachen, die ich auch gerne hätte unter Windows.
Zum Beispiel eine gescheite Oberfläche mit i3.
Oder auch die ganzen anderen Tools wie ein ordentliches Terminal und sowas.
Ist deutlich angenehmer.
Also generell Technik Sachen zu machen unter Linux ist viel viel angenehmer als das unter Windows zu machen.
Privacy.
Beste.
Why are you reading this?
Ja.
Das ist eine berechtigte Frage.
Earn.
Freedom.
What I've gathered so far is that it's free.
You can customize everything on Linux.
And a lot of people say that it's the best.
Now obviously there are many people that use their computers for a variety of different reasons.
So here's what I use it for.
I use my Mac mainly for video editing in Adobe Premiere Pro.
Making thumbnails in Adobe Photoshop.
Writing.
Recording videos.
Screen recordings or voiceovers.
Doing your normal everyday things in the browser.
And light gaming.
And by light I mean helium light.
Very light because it's Mac OS.
Now on Windows I do heavy duty gaming.
Hardcore Super Macs.
That's probably the name of some phone out there.
And also some video editing sometimes.
Also I'm already aware that there's no Adobe software on Linux.
And a few games that I play that have anti-cheat like CS2.
What anti-cheat?
Don't really work on Linux.
But let's not get ahead of ourselves.
My goal right now is just to...
He?
Hat er jetzt gesagt CS geht nicht oder was?
...on Linux.
And a few games that I play that have anti-cheat like CS2.
What anti-cheat?
Don't really work on Linux.
But let's not get ahead of ourselves.
My goal right now is just to install Linux and explore all the different things that you can do with it.
Anyway I chose to go with the Mint version of Linux first because it's best for beginners aka me.
So let us begin the installation.
First I'm googling Linux Mint.
And here on the homepage I will be able to find the Linux version.
Boink
And if I scroll down I'll be able to choose between the Cinnamon edition...
Sleek, Modern and Intuitive.
Die würde ich nehmen auch an seiner Stelle.
Let's just go with this one.
Since it's three gigabytes this should take some time.
The next thing we'll need is...
Let's just go with this one.
Since it's three gigabytes this should take some time.
The next thing we'll need is called Belena Etcher.
It's basically a software...
Naja, es gibt auch noch zig andere Varianten ein ISO off'n USB Stick zu kriegen.
zu kriegen. Kann Windows nicht mittlerweile
ISOs von Haus aus flashen?
Also von Haus aus mounten kannst
das. Das ist halt so ein typisches
Ding, da denkt man
überhaupt nicht dran, dass das überhaupt ein Ding ist,
dass man Zusatzsoftware braucht. Unter
Linux brauchst du einfach nichts
an Zusatzsoftware, um den ISO auf den
USB-Stick zu flashen.
Ich bin faul, ich benutze auch
manchmal Etcher oder den Raspberry Pi
Flasher, aber du brauchst
einfach nichts dafür.
Zusätzlich.
Er, well, Blena Etcher
is a free and open source. Okay, essentially
we need this to put this Linux
Mint file onto a USB-Stick.
So I'm going to download this as well. Now the
current plan is to install Windows
on my D-Drive. This one right
here. This is an SSD that I yoinked
from my laptop and installed it on my
new desktop PC and it's actually
the one that I nuked before with the previous
Linux installation. Actually it should have
more space. While things are still downloading
I'll open Disk Utility. I mean
create and format hard disk partitions.
Utility or Disk Management.
And here let's quickly find the
SSD, which is here. And as you can
see it has these two partitions, which I
used before for Linux.
Let's make sure
that it's empty now. And it is empty.
So I'm going to right-click, delete
volume and delete volume here as well.
And delete this one as well.
Now my D-Drive is
gone. So to put it back, I'm going to
create a new simple volume. Make sure it's
the maximum size. Assign the D-Letter
for these nuts and click
next a bunch of times. So I have my new
D-Drive with a little more space
for Linux. Also if you want to
rename your disk, you can double-click
on the name and rename it to
whatever you want. So I'm going
to open the... Also das war komplett
überflüssig. Das hätte es überhaupt
nicht gebraucht.
Ja, das kriegen wir auch hin.
So, und dann habe ich hier
meine USB und Flash.
Joink, a white blob opened up,
which means that there's some processing going
on. And there is some processing
going on. And mission successful.
Now I can safely delete the Linux
Mint ISO file and also the
Balena Etcher installer and also
Balena Etcher itself. I'm going
to open the file location, then
go to local and yeet it out
to the trash. Warum hat das nicht einen aninstallen?
Das war einfach... Ja, egal. Egal, egal.
So next, the goal is to restart my computer.
And somehow boot into that USB.
So that it loads whatever is on the
USB and not Windows. So now
I have to figure out how to get to the boot
menu on my motherboard. Ja, F2
hämmern, F11, F12, F...
Entfernen, was auch immer.
Which gave me a PDF link
Im Zweifelsfall entfernen hämmern.
To enter BIOS at startup press delete or F2.
So essentially I need to restart my computer
and smash the delete. Ne, also bei mir
ist es glaube ich entfernt.
Aber ich glaube ich kann auf F12 auch direkt
ein Bootmenü aufmachen.
Ich versuch den noch zu installieren.
So let's do this procedure.
By the way, function question mark is delete for me
because I have a 60% keyboard.
Ja, mag ich nicht.
Oh, didn't work.
Boom, we're inside BIOS. Now down here
it says boot menu and I need to press
F8 to get to the boot menu.
So I'm going to press F8
and here I can select my USB.
Wie fancy mittlerweile
die BIOS setups sind, ja.
UEFI.
So richtig mit high res und
Mausbedienung.
Für mich muss ein BIOS
so richtig oldschool
quasi weißer Text auf blauem
Hintergrund Tastatur only sein.
Nur dann
geht das durch als echtes
als echte
Experience.
So muss ein BIOS aussehen, Leute.
BIOS screen.
So muss das, so oder
so ehrlich gesagt. Nur nicht mal so.
So muss das aussehen.
Nur dann ist das
das viele, echte.
One and click enter and
Maus support in BIOS.
And a mouse.
And boom, we are in.
Now this whole thing here is like a temporary
space that I can tinker with
if I want. But if I restart my computer
everything will be reset to what you
see here. Because I still need to install
Linux Mint and there's a little
CD here that will let me do that.
CD's nuts. So I'm going to click on
install Linux Mint and now
it will let me actually install.
Das hab ich schon wieder ganz vergessen, ja.
Heads und Zylinder bei Festplatten.
Gab's da nicht noch ne dritte
Sache, die man einstellen
musste? Heads, Zylinder,
was? Gab's da nicht drei Sachen,
die man einstellen musste?
Sektoren?
Also du musstest auf jeden Fall
an deinem IDE Kabel gucken,
neben deinem IDE Kabel, ob die
Jumper richtig gesetzt sind.
Ja.
Nicht, dass man etwa Festplatte
und CD Laufwerk an einem
gleichen IDE Kabel hatte und das
CD Laufwerk Master war und die Festplatte
Slave. Eine Bezeichnung,
die heutzutage hoch fragwürdig
wäre. Wie kennt ihr
nicht?
IDE Jumper. Ja.
So sah das aus.
IDE Kabel
und dann musstest du Jumpern.
Als was das ganze, ja
guck hier sieht mans. Ja, du konntest das
Jumpern auf Master Slave.
Was auch immer.
Was? Ne, das mein ich nicht.
Ja.
Master of Single Drive, Drive for
Slave, Master of Cable Slave,
Alter, ja.
Ja und noch Kompatibilitätsmodus,
genau. Beste.
Nein, nicht wirklich beste,
aber coole
Sachen damals. Da kam man sich richtig
wieder Ultra Hackerman vor.
Wenn man sowas gesetzt hat, dann hat's
funktioniert.
Kann mich noch dran erinnern, ich musste mal eine
ISA Fritz Card
installieren in dem Rechner damals.
So ein Ding, ja.
Ne, das ist schon PCI Express.
ISA.
Ja sowas hier, genau.
Und die hatte Jumper drauf.
Hat der hier vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr
Bilder von?
Und die hatte Jumper drauf.
Für Interrupts.
Das heißt, du hast dann Windows installiert,
bist in Gerätemanager gegangen,
hast festgestellt, Windows hat den
falschen Interrupt assigned,
dann hast du den Rechner aufgeschraubt,
das konntest du nicht so einfach umstellen,
dann hast du den Rechner aufgeschraubt
und hast den Jumper umgesetzt
auf die Adresse, die Windows angezeigt hat,
und dann ging's. Fritz, das war damals eine
ISDN Karte, so haben die Dinge angefangen.
Die gibt's schon, die gibt's schon
richtig lange. Nicht ISA
Fritz.
Ja, immer.
Also ich mag den,
ich mag den Mint Cursor,
deswegen hab ich den auch unter
I3 hier, das ist der
in gelb bei mir, ja,
die gleiche Cursor-Family
wie Mint auch hat.
Man dürft dir raten, was heute zu essen gibt.
Den mag ich, diese Sorte Cursor.
Also,
ich hab den auch unter
I3 hier, das ist der
in gelb bei mir, ja,
die gleiche Cursor-Family wie
Mint Cursor.
Das ist auch
cool, wie einfach das ist.
Früher war das immer eine Wissenschaft
für sich, die Festplatte so zu formatieren.
Beziehungsweise umzuparitionieren,
das Windows parallel drauf.
Hat Windows eigentlich immer noch die Probleme
mit der Uhrzeit, wenn du Linux bootest,
dass dann die Uhrzeit nicht mehr stimmt?
Das kann man aber bestimmt fixen mit irgendeinem
Shutdown-Skript oder so für Linux.
Das ist das, was ich hören möchte.
Nun, da geht sie.
Okay, es ist wahrscheinlich wichtig,
dass ich das mit diesen Bedingungen verstehe.
Die Partition-Tabelle der folgenden Geräte sind
Seriously, wenn du übelster
Kacknub bist, hast du keine Ahnung,
was das hier eigentlich bedeuten soll.
Also, wenn du wirklich keine Ahnung von hast und installierst das,
dann sagst du einfach continue, weil du es eh nicht verstehst.
Ich meine, die meisten Leute wissen
auch noch nicht mal, dass Linux Standard Mesh X4 verwendet.
Geschweige denn,
dass irgendjemand weiß, was eine ESP ist.
Leute,
ihr seid High-IQ-Chat.
Was ist eine, wofür ist die ESP-Partition da?
Die braucht man übrigens
nur bei etwas neueren.
EFI-System-Partition,
ja, genau, richtig.
EFI-Boot, korrekt.
Ja.
Das heißt, es gibt eine ESP-Partition.
Ich glaube, das ist die Format,
die meine SSD geben wird.
Und Partition 3 meiner SSD
als XT4.
Vielleicht bedeutet das XFAT,
das ist auch eine Format,
die Hard-Drives sind.
Aber von dem, was es aussieht,
beeinflusst sich nur diese SSD,
die für mich aktuell leer ist.
Also, klicken wir weiter.
Aber er ist schon mal nicht so weit davon entfernt.
Installation has finished.
Once I restart, I should be in.
Und jetzt bootet er erstmal in Windows.
Äh, in Windows.
And boom!
Welcome to Linux Mint.
This screen will guide you. Let's go.
Let's go with dark mode.
We have a few styles here.
Let's keep it like this for now.
Let's go into advanced settings.
Change the mouse pointer.
Warum? Nein! Das ist der beste, Alter!
Das ist der beste Cursor, den es gibt.
Ich hab den nicht umsonst auch unter nicht Linux Mint.
Oh, very nice.
The applications from this blue color
to something like purple.
The icons to something like
yarrow purple dark.
Everything just changed down there.
And our desktop, let's change to
mint y purple.
Okay, that was easy.
I'll come back to all of these settings later.
Before I continue, I'm going to look for
display settings.
And hopefully I can increase the user interface.
Oh, scaling unter Linux Mint.
Ehm...
Ich ahne Schlimmes.
Scale, so that everything becomes bigger.
That is too big.
Let's go into settings.
Das ist so ein Ding.
Das ist wirklich eines der ganz großen Schwachpunkte
für Linux on desktop, wenn du High DPI Displays hast
und ordentliches scalen willst.
Jetzt kommen die Leute für dich.
Ja, aber mit Wayland ist das alles viel besser.
Ja, Wayland hat andere Probleme.
Aber das ist so ein Ding.
Ich ahne Schlimmes.
Das ist wie bei den aktiven Scaling Kontrollen.
Ich erinnere mich, dass das nicht richtig funktioniert hat.
Aber hoffentlich funktioniert das besser.
Lass uns 150 % machen.
Ja, das funktioniert nicht.
Also, lass uns jetzt bis 100 % machen.
Wir hätten gedacht, dass das nicht funktioniert.
Eines der Dinge, was ich bemerke, ist, dass die Maus-Akseleration
wahrscheinlich angewandert ist.
Ich werde also versuchen, für die Settings zu suchen.
Ja, das waren System Settings.
Oh, Acceleration. Konstant. Ja, konstant, bitte.
Oh, viel besser.
Okay, let's not get sidetracked.
I think I need to install some graphics card drivers
for the display scaling to work properly.
Ah, ich weiß nicht, ob das das wirklich fixt.
No drivers needed.
Your computer does not need any additional drivers.
Never mind.
Okay, so why can't I go into display settings
and change my refresh rate, for example?
It's not supposed to be 93 Hz.
Das mit der Refreshrate, das könnte tatsächlich an der Grafikkarte liegen.
It's supposed to be 144 Hz, but it says unknown display.
So immediately I'm having random problems.
Let's minimize this thing and try to...
Und jetzt ist das, was ich bei mir in meinem Video gesagt habe.
Du wirst früher oder später nicht am Terminal vorbeikommen.
Was man jetzt machen muss, ist den Browser öffnen,
nach seinen Problemen suchen
und dann nach irgendwelchen Guides Terminal-Kommandos ausführen.
Wie gesagt, für mich ist das eines der größten Vorteile von Linux.
Das ist eben so eine gute CLI-Experience,
wie man sowas nennt.
Heute hat...
Aber viele haben ja Schiss vor der Kommandozeile.
Was man als längerer Linux-User nicht verstehen kann.
Aber wenn man nur Windows benutzt
und nur von früher CMD kennt,
dann kann ich verstehen, dass die Leute Schiss davor haben.
Also, du kommst nicht drum herum.
Genau, du musst danach suchen, Terminal aufmachen,
Kommandos reinpacen, fassen.
Moment.
NeoFetch ist outdated.
Das verwendet man.
Das verwendet man heute nicht mehr, Leute.
Man verwendet kein NeoFetch mehr.
Guck.
Deswegen, weil man kein NeoFetch mehr verwendet,
nur noch Loops verwenden NeoFetch,
habe ich NeoFetch auf FastFetch-Aliast.
Und das hat uns sogar letztens
die Linux-Oma
auf YouTube erzählt.
Wenn uns sogar die Linux-Oma auf YouTube schon erzählt,
dass NeoFetch outdated ist,
ja,
dann ist das auch so.
Es sagt, dass mein CPU,
mein Prozessor,
ist der aktuelle Prozessor, den ich benutze.
Aber dann sagt es, dass mein GPU
das AMD-ATI-Device ist.
Das ist nicht mein GPU.
Das ist...
Die macht seit Jahren schon Video über Linux.
Ich habe die auch erst zufällig,
weil ich gesucht habe nach NeoFetch,
wurde mir auch dieses Video vorgeschlagen.
Und seitdem,
ich wusste nicht, dass es die gibt.
Ja.
Und dann habe ich mir den Channel mal angeguckt.
Kann ich dir zeigen.
Die macht seit Jahren schon ein Video über Linux.
Die macht seit Jahren schon Linux-Videos.
Mittlerweile ist er auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Aber wenn die Linux-Oma das sagt, dann ist das so.
Probably right now, Linux isn't finding my graphics card.
Which is probably fixable.
Oh, wait.
I forgot. To paste something into the terminal,
you press not Ctrl-V,
but Ctrl-Shift-V.
Professional Linux-Mann.
Okay, what the hell is this?
Haha, jetzt geht's los.
Haha, ja.
Das ist halt die Linux-Experience,
das ist halt die Linux-Experience,
wenn du neu bist und einfach nur ohne Plan zu haben Tutorials durchmachst.
Ich sag das jetzt nicht als negativ,
aber du hast ja keinen Plan, wenn du anfängst.
Das ist genau das Ding.
Und das ist auch das, was ich in meinem Video damals meinte.
Ich hab ja so ein Video,
zu dem Thema gemacht.
Und da spreche ich genau solche Sachen an.
Das ist aber auch okay.
Ja, man muss sich da plus drauf einlassen.
Und das war ja eigentlich mein Punkt,
dass man nicht damit rangehen sollte,
ich installiere mir Linux,
kann das dann einfach wie Windows benutzen,
ohne die nervigen Sachen von Windows zu haben.
Das ist halt nicht so.
Das ist ein anderes Betriebssystem.
Man muss sich da drauf einlassen,
dass man ein bisschen Abstriche in einem Bereich machen muss,
eventuell allerdings dafür Vorteile haben.
Es ist ein anderes System.
Da muss man dann durch.
Man kann nicht erwarten,
ich installiere das und benutze es wie Windows,
nur ohne die nervigen Sachen von Windows.
Das ist das, was ich in dem Video sagen wollte.
Und...
Das mochten viele Leute nicht.
Das haben viele Leute echt als...
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max.
Ich meine, Leute,
teilweise habe ich früher die Sachen
bei weitem nicht so diplomatisch gesagt,
wie in diesem Video.
Aber trotzdem hast du wieder irgendwelche
Fanboys, die sich
übelst, übelst aufregen,
was ich da gesagt habe.
Es hat ja sogar einer reactet
auf... Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich muss mal gucken.
Also wenn ihr wirklich Gehirnschaden
bekommen wollt, müsst ihr euch die Kommentare
unter diesem Reaction-Video angucken.
Gegen das Reaction-Video sage ich gar nichts.
Das haben wir uns sogar mal zusammen
angeguckt. Das ist echt in Ordnung.
Da kannst du überhaupt nichts sagen gegen.
Aber wenn ihr mal richtig Gehirnschaden
bekommen wollt, müsst ihr euch
manche Kommentare hier drunter durchlesen.
Und am besten ist immer noch der Typ
gewesen unter meinem Video,
unter meinem Video, der gemeint hat,
ich soll den anderen, der reactet hat, anzeigen.
Ah ja, wenn er dieses Scheiß suche
auf... Ah, ich dreh am Rad, ey.
Warum ist das so schle...
Ja, hier, der Typ.
Lässt sich schlecht sein. Er nimmt das Video
hier unsachlich aus. Ich würde dir anraten,
wirklich vorzugehen.
Teilweise weiß ich nicht, was abgeht
mit den Leuten, ne. Das ist 100
pro auch jemand, der auf Facebook
Boomer-Witze, unanständige Eierwitze
zu Ostern auf Facebook postet.
Also der Commentschreiber.
Nicht der hier, der unter
meinem Video...
Wait a minute, das...
Ach, ich hab das zweimal auf, Alter.
No idea what that means.
Asus is my
motherboard, so I'm assuming that
this one is my dedicated graphics
card.
Das ist LSHW Output, oder?
This one
is a built-in graphics card.
That doesn't tell me anything.
By the way, if you're dualbooting Windows
and Linux, like I'm doing right now, which
means you're using Linux and Windows
on the same computer, you can access the
files that you have on Windows from
Linux, which is very nice. Let's go into
Users, My User, Wallpapers
and boom, we can
yoink a wallpaper.
Very nice.
That tells a lot.
Now my GPU
shows up. What does this mean?
Moment, was hat er jetzt gemacht?
Was soll er machen?
sudo update pc?
Alter,
mir war bis eben nicht klar, dass
dieses Commando überhaupt existiert.
Update PC?
PCI-IDs?
What?
Now my GPU shows up. Does this mean that
I can scale my display?
Nein, please now it shows up.
Rebooten.
Welcome to Update Manager. This tool provides
your operating system with software and
security updates. Oh, this might update
everything and maybe that fixes
the display settings issue. Boom!
Okay, reboot required.
So I'm going to restart and hopefully it's
fixed. And we're back in. For some reason
the welcome screen is back and the
moment of truth, that's not good.
I still can't change the resolution or
the refresh rate. Can I set a different
scaling other than 100 or 200?
No, perfect. Just what I like
to see. So I'm going to stick with trying
to solve this issue first and once
I do... Das ist halt tatsächlich
für neue Leute die Linux
Experience. Da musst du durch.
Es könnte durchaus
besser sein, aber
es ist einfach kein Drop-in
Replacement an vielen Stellen, wie
sich das manche so vorstellen oder wie einem das
die ja manche
Videos verkaufen wollen.
Es ist bei dem jetzt
das Problem. Das heißt nicht, dass es bei
jemand anderem exakt das gleiche Problem ist,
aber auf ähnliche Sachen stößt du
halt immer mal wieder.
Und jetzt
fangt erst mal an Soundprobleme
zu debuggen.
Der Kernel ist zu alt.
Mag ja sein, also was mich überhaupt wundert,
warum das und so.
Auf was basiert das?
Ja gut, das ist Ubuntu LTS, oder?
Mint.
Also noch auf
2204 wahrscheinlich.
Oder auf 2204?
2204 ist halt zwei Jahre alt.
Ich glaube das nächste
Mint ist dann wahrscheinlich
auf 2404.
Aber das musst du
auch erstmal wissen. Dann ist er mit
Linux Mint hat er wahrscheinlich gelitten, oder?
Kann man bei Linux Mint irgendwie...
Also bei Arch kannst du ja ohne Probleme
hier sagen,
kannst du hier unterschiedliche Kernel
auswählen. Ich habe unter Manjaro
habe ich immer das Manjaro
Kernel Settings Tool verwendet. Weiß gar nicht, wie man
den Kernel switcht unter Arch.
Ich habe nur LTS und den normalen Kernel entsteht.
Aber wenn du den Kernel
austauschen kannst, ja gegen welchen Kernel
tauscht du denn den aus?
Wenn das auf Ubuntu 2204 basiert, gibt's
doch nur einen, oder?
Amd GPU, der sollte
einfacher sein.
Okay, was ich bis jetzt gesammelt habe, ist, dass
wenn ich Driver N A sehe
und hier, innerhalb von
Systeminformationen, neben meinem
Grafikkarten, kann ich Sapphire
Driver N A sehen. Und hier sagt es auch
Asus Driver N A.
Was bedeutet, dass der Kernel
den Driver nicht gesteckt hat. Zumindest
jetzt weiß ich, was passiert. Open Source
Driver, insbesondere Intel und Amd, sind
in den Linux Kernel eingeführt. In den meisten Fällen,
wenn diese Driver nicht gesteckt werden, bedeutet das,
dass der Kernel, der aktuell verwendet wird,
zu alt ist, um die notwendigen Driver zu haben.
Okay, das scheint versichert zu sein.
Gehen wir in den Update Manager.
Du hast bestimmt gecheatet und das Video schon vorher gesehen.
Gib's zu.
Kernels. Ich bin hier schon vorher.
Und ich brauche den 6.5
Kernel, welcher hier ist.
Installation, glaube ich. Boink.
Vielleicht funktioniert das. Okay, wir starten wieder
und sehen, was jetzt passiert.
Wir sind zurück. Die Startup-Screen ist wieder hier.
Jetzt geht's.
Weißt du, warum ich denke, dass es jetzt geht?
Viele Sachen, gerade die Hardware-
related sind, die gehen unter
Linux einfach out of the box,
wenn es der Kernel unterstützt. Oder
es ist ein Riesenakt
mit zusätzlichen Kernel-Modulen
und sonst was.
Deswegen sage ich jetzt einfach mal, es geht.
Out of the box. Easy.
Nice.
Es hat nur zwei Stunden gedauert.
Let's go into the settings and explore
what we can do here. Backgrounds.
There are a bunch of included backgrounds.
Of course, I'm going to use my background.
Link in the description. Let's go into effects.
New windows or unminimizing existing ones.
Traditional, fly...
Was ist der neueste Linux-User?
Du meinst meinen Vater, oder wen?
Nee.
Der hat tatsächlich noch keine
komischen Toolbars installiert.
Aber der hat auch
irgendwelche komischen...
Sachen wieder getrieben. Der hat es geschafft.
Ich habe ihm ja... Der braucht ja nichts, ne?
Der braucht einen Browser und das war's.
Ich habe ihm
das Chrome-Icon gepinnt
unten bei Linux Mint auf der Leiste
und er hat es irgendwie geschafft, das Chrome-Icon zu löschen.
Keine Ahnung wie.
Das war auf einmal weg und er wusste
nicht mal, wie er Chrome startet.
Ist so. Ja, ja. Die meisten Leute
wären nicht so weit gekommen. Die hätten
schon wieder abgebrochen. Das ist ja auch genau
das, was ich in meinem Video gesagt habe.
Da muss ich darauf einlassen.
Sonst wird das nichts.
Es ist kein 1 zu 1 Windows-Replacement.
Was gut ist,
weil es viel angenehmer ist in vielen
Fällen als Windows. Aber
viele denken sich halt,
ah, Windows fuckt mich ab,
ich installiere mir Linux, dann benutze ich das wie
Windows, nur ohne die nervigen Sachen. Aber es ist halt
einfach nicht so.
Ja, aber der ist glaube ich gerade im Krankenhaus, also
der macht gerade auch nichts unter Linux kaputt.
Bock zieht durch
hier.
Das stimmt wohl.
Das verstehe ich auch nicht.
Ich bilde mir ein, unter Windows gab es früher
ein Windows-Track-Icon.
Aber das gibt es seit Windows 8
oder so nicht mehr.
Wo ist das eigentlich hin?
So gibt's das noch. Guck mal.
So.
Guck mal.
Das funktioniert übrigens
nicht mehr. Hier.
Hier. Das funktioniert einfach nicht mehr.
Das kannst du nicht mehr.
Da wer jetzt denkt, das tut
einfach nicht mehr.
Moment, ich muss die fucking Taster...
Ach jetzt! Jetzt hängt's auf einmal
am Fä...
Es ist so dumm einfach nur, Alter.
Wer baut denn so was?
the default arrow cursor what do we have in accessibility high contrast that's nice except
the icons are not super nice actions add desklets create a new launcher display settings oh i think
this is the right click menu add desklets change desktop background it's here so you can customize
your right click menu and you can download more things that you can add into your right click
menu that's cool you can add something that will restart your computer or you can take a
screenshot just from the right click menu pretty cool davinci audio das ist so ein ding das mag
ich gar nicht so sehr weil das ist so ein so ein so ein so ein so ein mint cinnamon only ding
man halt sagt ey das benutzt eh keiner das sind irgendwelche low quality scripts
da würde ich mich nicht darauf verlassen adjustment i should actually try editing
applets what the hell are applets the applet will let you add icons so oh so it's here probably
these are called applets
applets in linux okay i select it and add plus it should appear here if i add
das ist noch als mäuse nicht so verbreitet waren ja klar deswegen brauche ich auch eine maus um
da oben rechts drauf zu klicken wobei ich glaube man kann irgendwie das auch so oft machen aber
it again it briefly appears and disappears okay what about the on-screen keyboard oh
this one works so if i click on it i will have the keyboard accessible for use with my mouse
scale i can quickly change the scale never mind this is mission control extensions
i don't have any extensions if i go into download you can download extensions transparent panels
g-tile tile your windows as you like so you can just install a bunch of moment da war es da war
es das wichtigste plugin leute habt ihr es gesehen wer hat es gespottet da ist es wobbly windows
es gibt einfach nichts besseres hätte ich was mit fenstern wobei ich habe ja streng genommen kann ja mein
i3 auch äh fenster ja tuner auf oder dass man ein bisschen was sieht also hätte ich fenster oh
alter tuner ist ja laggy beim resizen what the fuck das ist by the way ein video von mir auf youtube
also nix falsches ding und schade dass es kein wobbly windows möglichkeiten gibt für i3 dann
hätte ich auch wobbly windows am start wobbly windows ist legit das beste was es gibt features
system just like that that's crazy we'll leave it for later hot corners i know what hot corners
are from mac os and they're really useful on mac os i have this corner set to show my desktop so
if i move my mouse here it should show the desktop das ist ein video das heißt eins zu eins ist bei mir
auf youtube channel da zeige ich bilder von meinem opa am dachboden okay panel oh this is where i can
customize the taskbar how can i move these to the middle hey how do i move this green
thing wer will denn sowas in der mitte haben das kann nur ein mac user sein der seine icons in der
mitte haben label what if i just do like this that looks nice i still haven't figured out oh now it
moved to the center okay so it was possible well never mind now everything is in the center and the
menus are over there preferred applications so this is where you hyperland kann ich nicht ausprobieren
weil hyperland nicht in der vm gescheit funktioniert applications windows buttons layout how is this
classic mac
let's just have them on the right action on title bar double click toggle maximize exactly what i want
action on title bar middle click so if i middle click with my mouse button nothing happens
minimize can i close toggle shade toggle minimize no i can only minimize i would like to close with
the middle click action on title close on middle click wer will denn sowas haben mac user just
opacity oh i can make them more or less visible i'm not sure bisher hat alles geklappt ja nach zwei
stunden grafikkarten gefunden i want that but that's the end of the video if you liked this video please subscribe to the channel and hit the bell so you won't miss any future videos and i will see you in the next video bye bye bye
there i love that when you hover over a setting it just explains what it is without me having
das ist in der tat ziemlich gut da kann also das muss man wirklich mal lassen da können sich diese
windows settings echt was was von abscheiden hier drinnen findest du nix und weißt oftmals nicht was
es macht location of newly opened windows automatic cursor manual center let's do it
es scheint richtig es scheint richtig drauf abzugehen hier
next to my cursor yes this is so good draggable border width look at how far the border stands
from where das ist wirklich praktisch weil wer kennt's nicht ich möchte mein fenster resizen und
ich muss halt genau fast genau auf dieses dreck where i can grab the window i love that you can
customize this there's a sound for when you close and minimize windows das ist nicht der close sound
hey let's just enable them okay so
those were the settings so now let's try to actually do something within linux my first idea
is to compile a list of things that i would normally do with the computer and try to accomplish it with
linux okay let's go pull up a text editor install an application take a screenshot easy a folder
alias how do you do this auf der kommandozeilen easy wie man das im gui macht keine ahnung
das ist eine gute frage moment moment ich glaube ich habe noch nie einen link erzeugt in der gui
okay
ich möchte jetzt dieses video hier verlinken ja ich habe keine ahnung ich habe absolut kein plan
wie ich einen link erstellen würde aber mal gucken ich würde den link ja auch ähnlich über tuna
erstellen i think that's it crop image convert image file format install a game play convert
image file format das wird ja schon mal ganz anders machen wie ich ich würde wahrscheinlich
mit ffm pack oder image magic
ascent war noch nichts ach desktop ja moment desktop link create ist falsch ich will nicht
desktop ich will hier link create ah wurscht wie gesagt ich würde es ähnlich über das google
install solid 12 tasks so first install an a application now there are a couple of
Ja, nur, dass es hässlich für die Nacht ist.
Und ganz ehrlich, wer sich das UI von GIMP ausgedacht hat,
äh, keine Ahnung, also per GIMP.
Also haben wir es durch den Software-Manager installiert
und jetzt kann ich es suchen, GIMP, und öffnen.
Oh, das hat tatsächlich schneller angefangen als Photoshop.
Ich habe das nicht erwartet.
Nächstes Mal versuchen wir, etwas durch den Terminal zu installieren.
Lass uns etwas wie VLC machen.
Also um etwas durch den Terminal zu installieren,
tust du sudo apt install und dann den Programm-Name.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass nur VLC nicht funktioniert.
Also muss ich noch herausfinden, was ich für VLC installieren muss.
VLC-Media-Player für Ubuntu.
Boom, sudo...
Snap!
Alter, Ubuntu!
Nein, nein, nein, das geht auch ziemlich sicher als normales Package,
nicht als Snap.
Ich hoffe, er macht nicht hier das Tor zur Snap-Hölle auf jetzt.
Snap, install VLC.
Does it work?
VLC is already the newest version.
I think it's already installed.
There it is.
So let's try another program, like Discord, for example.
Discord install Linux.
Well, that's the third way, I suppose.
It's downloading a file with the DEB extension,
which means Debian, I think.
And basically Linux Mint is from...
Discord gibt es doch auch über den App Store, oder?
...the Debian Linux family.
So it should work.
Now I download it into my Downloads-Folder.
And here it is.
If I double-click, it should install Discord.
Install Package.
An unhandable error occurred.
Can't close this for some reason.
What's all that for on Linux?
How do you force quit something?
Das kannst du...
Mittlerweile kannst du doch auch über das Software-Center Flatpacks installieren.
Und Flatpacks von Discord sind auch immer aktuell.
Okay.
Das wäre wahrscheinlich die bessere Variante gewesen als das DEB-File.
Let's leave this to the side for now until we get back to it.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man das, wie man Xkill vom GUI ausmacht.
And let's see how to install Discord.
Linux Mint stands on the shoulders of giants.
It's based on Debian and Ubuntu.
So the Debian installer should work.
Install Package.
Same version is already installed.
So did it install before and just gave me a random error.
Oh, Discord is already here.
Das ist ein Fehler wahrscheinlich, weil es irgendein Debian-spezifisches,
Post-Hook-Install-Skript laufen lassen wollte.
Und das ist fehlgeschlagen.
There we have Discord.
Or discordapp.com slash app question mark 1273.
So we can safely say that we installed an application.
Now I want to complete the bonus thing that I added.
Force quit an app.
I'm not sure if this is an app, but it's definitely something that has crashed.
So I want to eliminate it from my field view.
Inside of the terminal type in sudo xkill.
Then click on any window to kill it.
Man muss das überhaupt nicht sudoen, oder?
Ein normales Xkill reicht doch auch.
Xkill.
Select the window whose client you wish to kill with button 1.
And it turned into an X-Cursor.
Boing.
That was really cool.
Take a screenshot.
Let's try and look for just a screenshot app.
Maybe it exists.
Screensaver.
No.
Oh, screenshot.
Take a screenshot.
Screen, window or selection.
Let's screenshot the calculator.
Ja, das haben die bei Linux Mint echt gut gemacht.
Die haben von den 50 Milliarden Programmen eine ganz gute Vorselection getroffen.
Take screenshot.
And that's the screenshot.
Okay.
Let's explore what's possible to do in this image app.
What if I go into edit?
Flip horizontal, vertical, rotate, rotate, move to trash, delete and preferences.
So it seems like there's no option to crop an image here.
Which is something that I'm...
Ja, useless.
Screenshot app ohne crop kannst du eigentlich knicken.
Would love to see, but I'm pretty sure that there's another photo app.
Beziehungsweise Image Editor ohne crop.
Ich würde es auch wundern, wenn er das nicht hat.
That lets you do that.
Side pane.
Image properties.
Name, width, height, type, file size.
This is really useful.
I'm keeping this on.
Okay.
Solid photos app.
Also I keep having to right click and move to trash instead of just being able to delete something.
So I'm going to find out a shortcut for deleting files.
Entfernen drücken?
Two ways to delete files on Linux.
First press delete button.
I know.
I was impressed too.
It doesn't let me though.
Oh, let's completely ignore that.
Create a folder alias.
I'm assuming you can create a new folder with ctrl shift n.
Just like on Windows or Mac.
And let's try to create an alias.
So right click and sharing options.
Properties.
Didn't work so well.
What if I do it inside of my file manager?
It doesn't seem like it's in this right click menu.
But I'm pretty sure that I can customize this right click menu.
What if I go to properties?
Permissions.
Share.
Emblems.
I can add an emblem to a folder?
Oh, that's crazy.
Anyway, so how do you make an alias?
It seems like all the answers are for making aliases through the terminal.
Which is fine.
But I want to just make it through the file.
Because I have no idea how to do it over GUI.
Copies it.
Shift.
That moves it.
Control.
Copies it as well.
Control alt.
Alt shift.
Control shift.
Control alt shift.
I'm running out of time.
Einfach mal durchprobieren.
How did I do that?
Link to Shrek.
So it's called link.
I think it was control shift.
Yes, it's control shift.
And then you drag.
Obviously control shift.
So if I open this, it should take me to my Shrek folder.
Selbst erklären.
I want to create a folder inside here.
So now Shrek 2 should be inside of Shrek as well.
Yes.
Didn't even have to use the terminal.
Crop image.
So as we've seen before, you can't really crop something inside of the photos app.
Let's actually go into the software manager and look for a different app for photos.
If you need a basic tool for image management, consider Pix.
Image.
Viewer and browser.
So I have this already, no?
Drawing or Pix.
Oh, this is like Microsoft Paint.
And there's a crop tool immediately there.
Boink.
Completely cropped.
Look at it now.
Convert image file format to another format.
Now you can very easily do this on Mac OS with the right click menu.
So let's see how hard.
Also ich wäre jetzt wieder GUI noob, wie ich bin.
Ich hätte es entweder über FFmpeg gemacht.
FFmpeg frisst ja auch Bilder.
Oder irgendwie was mit Image Magic.
It's going to be on Linux.
I'm assuming I can just do this.
I can just do that within the drawing app.
Aber wahrscheinlich hätte ich es einfach über FFmpeg gemacht, ja?
So hier Download.
Haben wir da irgendein Bild?
Ja, White BG, FFmpeg, Minus I, White BG und ich will White BG PNG.
So, easy.
What?
Äh, nicht Minus O, Minus I.
Zack.
Und schon haben wir ein PNG.
Was man sogar mit VLC, was bescheuert ist, VLC öffnen kann.
Warum auch immer man VLC als Image Viewer verwenden sollte.
Aber VLC zeigt halt einfach alles an.
Man kann auch einfach, ja, ich kann auch mein Terminal.
Zehn Sekunden.
Das Image ist groß, das ist 4K Bild.
Okay, ich kann auch auf dem Terminal einfach das Bild anzeigen lassen.
Viel besser.
Und keinen Unterschied zu erkennen zwischen.
Achso, man kann da gar nicht zwei Stück reinschreiben, okay.
Ja doch, das PNG ist nicht so.
Da unterschiedliche Sachen, oder?
Das ist ein ganz anderes Bild.
Terminal, das geht, ja.
Das geht aber nur, wenn du ein Terminal hast, was Images unterstützt.
Und ich benutze Westterm.
Und da ist ein Programm eingebaut, was Images anzeigen kann.
Westterm ist eh das beste Terminal überhaupt.
Ich hab das jetzt seit ein paar Jahren schon.
Und ich hab keinerlei.
Ambitionen nach was anderem.
Oh, Kitty hat auch so seine Probleme.
Kitty hat, der Kitty-Typ ist sehr merkwürdig.
Beispielsweise was SSH-T-Mux-Nutzung angeht und so.
Different format, nevermind.
I mean, I can type in a different extension, but I'd like to choose.
Okay, so is it actually JPEG now?
Type, JPEG.
Oh, so I just had to change the file name extension that it's going to be saved with.
Not the way I imagined it would go, but look at the masterpiece that we created.
Install a game.
Let's pick a game that doesn't have a JPEG.
Let's pick a game that doesn't have anti-cheat.
Something like, I don't know, Minecraft.
Let's try Minecraft.
Ja gut, Minecraft läuft easy unter Linux.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ist das die Java-Version oder ist das...
Kann man auch die neue C++-Version unter Linux gut laufen lassen?
Arch, by the way.
Downloaded the file once again.
Install package.
Continue.
Same version already installed.
And that's it.
I should have Minecraft.
Let's put the masterpiece here safely.
I mean, it's setting everything up.
So that's pretty good.
And I think we're in.
Minecraft launcher.
While it's downloading, let's explore some more.
Dann wann braucht man eigentlich ein Login für Minecraft?
Versorptions.
DMZ Black.
Ich bin nicht so im Minecraft-Game.
Oh, so we have successfully installed a game.
Okay.
Let's try to play the game.
Now I have to say, playing Minecraft wasn't an issue on Linux.
Nicht schon immer.
But screen recording.
Ich musste mich da nicht einloggen beim Starten.
It was a horrible nightmare.
Look at this.
Oh, this recording.
What is that?
What are all of these weird artifacts?
I can't even see anything.
Now I did this with an app called Simple Screen Recorder.
And you may have noticed that in different parts of the video,
there are these weird artifacts.
I guess the screen recorder is so simple, it just records a blob.
And after trying a bunch of different settings with the Simple Screen Recorder,
I decided to try and use good old OBS,
which is essentially a go-to screen recording software for Windows.
That one was even worse.
Trying to record any gameplay footage on Linux either gives me this weird mess,
or just a single frame like this for the whole recording.
So that's that.
But the game itself works great.
So Minecraft worked, but I wasn't able to show it.
Use virtual desktops.
Now we're getting to the fun stuff.
I'm pretty sure you can switch virtual desktops with Ctrl-Alt and right and left arrow.
Oh, they're called workspaces.
Let's do Ctrl-Alt and up, which...
Das ist halt alles Mix-Wörter.
Was ist Kompitz mit Würfel?
Kompitz mit Würfel und Wobbly Windows.
Das war einfach das Ding überhaupt.
Besser ging's nicht.
...should reveal them and I can add more and switch between them.
Now I'm wondering what happens if I have two Firefox Windows like this
and then I put one of them inside my first workspace.
Can I switch between them with Ctrl-Tab?
No.
So if you use Ctrl-Tab, you'll only be able to see apps that are open within this workspace.
If I switch to my first workspace,
I can now see all of the apps that are open in this workspace.
So they're essentially completely separated, which is pretty cool.
And we used virtual desktops.
Multitask with keyboard shortcuts.
Well, this can mean a variety of different things,
but what I meant here was snapping Windows
and also opening and switching between apps with the keyboard.
So I'm assuming the Windows key or the Super Key and the right arrow snaps.
The left one also snaps.
The top one...
Oh, why does it do this?
I never use this.
I always max my keyboard top.
So now when I want to max...
Okay, wie du es machst?
Ich mache es gleich durch.
...mach ich ein Window, muss ich nicht einmal, sondern zweimal drücken.
Hoffentlich kann ich das...
Das würde ich eh nicht benutzen.
Lass uns sehen.
Wenn ich sowas haben will, wie gesagt,
Tiling Window Manager, beste.
Es ist nicht so großartig.
Also essentiell die Super Key oder die Windows Key und die Arro-Keys
snap Windows zu verschiedenen Plätzen deines Screens.
Es ist nicht so stark wie Allthread oder Spotlight auf macOS.
Aber ich bin ziemlich sicher, dass es eine App gibt, die für Linux ist,
die ein ähnliches Set von Featuren hat wie Allthread.
Es ist essentiell wie...
Es gibt ein paar, die das versucht haben nachzubauen.
Ich habe noch nichts gefunden.
Es gibt ein paar, die verschiedene Apps öffnen, File,
die Kalkulationen machen und sogar...
Also ich benutze hier HoFi für alles.
Also für das, für das.
Das kannst du aber von den Features her nicht damit wirklich vergleichen.
Aber so als Launcher ist das geil.
Beste.
...quick Kalkulationen hier?
Nein.
Also ja, ich werde wahrscheinlich eine App suchen,
die ähnlich wie Allthread ist, die diese Feature hinzufügt.
Es gibt keine Art, dass sie nicht existiert.
Außerdem bin ich sicher, dass Tiling Window Managers existieren,
die im Grunde genommen
zwischen verschiedenen Apps und Only...
Eher, dass es da Sachen für gibt, kann ich mir schon durchaus vorstellen.
Aber du hast trotzdem aber nicht so viele Möglichkeiten damit.
...Keyboard-Shortcuts.
Zum Beispiel etwas wie...
Brauche das auch gar nicht.
...would take me to Firefox and so on.
But I'm not going to try one out for this video.
Create a folder using the terminal.
I know how to do this on MacOS.
So hopefully it works the same on Linux.
Ja, da hat er Glück,
dass das im Prinzip die gleiche Shell ist unter Linux wie Mac.
Und die gleichen Standard-Tools.
Letztendlich ist unter der Haube Mac OS.
Ja, mal ein FreeBSD.
Oh, nee, was war Mac OS unter der Haube mal?
Ja, aber welches?
Also das Playstation-Betriebssystem war mal ein FreeBSD unter der Haube.
Mac bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, welches BSD.
Let's do LS, which means list,
to see where the hell I am in my file system.
I'm pretty sure this is the user folder.
Let's double check.
Or maybe it's the home folder.
It has all of these listed out.
So let's create a folder on the desktop.
Let's first go into the desktop.
So CD for change directory.
And then desk.
There's autocomplete.
Very nice.
So now I'm on my desktop.
And to create a new folder,
I'm pretty sure it's mkdir for make directory.
It's a fancy name.
Wie gesagt, er hat Glück,
dass das unter Mac und Linux die gleichen Tools sind.
And let's name it Shrek.
How long ago did I make the terminal video?
Three months ago.
And I still haven't forgot this.
Very nice.
Let's install a program.
Let's install something so that I can uninstall something.
Let's do Obsidian.
And it's installed.
So the first way to uninstall something
is straight from the software manager.
I can just click remove.
That's the first way.
The second way is to go into your start menu
or the Linux menu.
Right click and choose uninstall.
The third way, I'm pretty sure there are more ways,
is of course by using the terminal.
I'm going to say sudo,
which is essentially run as administrator.
Apt, this is the package manager.
Think of it like...
Jetzt muss er nur wissen, wie Obsidian heißt.
Ich wette mit euch, das Package heißt nicht einfach Obsidian.
Das heißt wahrscheinlich Obsidian Desktop, Obsidian Notes oder sowas.
Aber man kann einfach danach suchen.
The software manager, where you can install a bunch of apps.
But there are just hundreds, if not thousands more apps
that you can install through it.
Then for installing something, you would say install.
But to uninstall, let's do remove.
And I'm going to paste in...
Ach, und es ist ein Flatpack.
Ja, dann ist es eh schon mal nett.
Dann eh schon mal nicht.
Never mind.
Let's just try Obsidian.
Maybe that works.
I'm pretty sure it won't work.
Yes.
Unable to install.
Unable to locate package Obsidian.
If you want to bring up the same command that you pasted in before,
just click the up arrow and it's back.
I'm not sure how to find out a name of a package
without going to the software manager
and then looking for the app that you installed.
Früher muss man sagen Apt Cache,
aber ich glaube mittlerweile kannst du...
Er hat Apt selbst in Search Command.
And here's the name.
Or of course I could use Google.
And then I'm pretty sure it's this name that I need to paste in here.
Nee, nee, das ist das Flatpack.
Obsidian dot Obsidian.
Does this work?
Nein, nein, das kann nicht.
Nein, das funktioniert nicht.
I'm pretty sure there's a way,
but I'm just going to uninstall it by right-clicking
and choosing uninstall.
There it is.
It's no longer here.
Install a font.
Let's do the Vsauce font.
You can place the font files somewhere under user...
Ach so, ja.
Das ist easy.
Ich dachte, er sucht es jetzt GUI-mäßig irgendwie.
Da weißt du nämlich gar nicht, wie man das macht.
...fonts.
So let's first open this one.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
ich würde wahrscheinlich den Font bei mir gar nicht runterladen,
sondern den Font über meinen Package Manager installieren,
weil es das...
Wo ich den Vorteil habe unter Arch Linux,
das ist so gut wie alles Mögliche,
sei es auch, wenn es nicht aus offiziellen Repos als User-Repo gibt,
sollte es doch mal einen Font geben,
den ich nicht über das Package Manager installieren kann.
Ja, dann würde ich auch so machen.
...and extract the font file.
Can I search for directories here?
No.
So, slash user is probably here.
Yes, I'm pretty sure it's called the root folder.
User, share, right-click, open as root,
basically means open as administrator, I'm pretty sure.
And if I put it here,
the font should be installed.
So if I type something here,
I should be able to go here and choose the Vsauce font,
which means that I installed it successfully.
Beautiful.
Check and access clipboard history.
I'm not sure this is possible,
so I'm immediately going to Google it.
The clipboard has no history, be default.
But you can add a clipboard manager...
Das mache ich auch mit Rofi, Clipboard Manager.
Ja, hier.
Keckel, Keckel.
Ah, copy-paste und Ctrl-P, da ist es.
Beste.
Und es ist sogar durchsuchbar.
Ich kann jetzt hier oben was eintippen hier.
Keckel, Server oder so, ihr seht's, ne?
Und dann zack.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Ja, da sind auch irgendwelche ollen Sachen aus der Shell drin.
Oh, nee, das ist Schrott.
Copy-Q mag ich überhaupt gar nicht.
Das ist eine Qt-Anwendung,
die so over-engineert,
die so geplotet ist,
dass ich mich frage,
warum es das überhaupt gibt.
Speichert sich das nach dem Neustart, ja.
Ha!
What a weird application.
Oh, Cinnamon just crashed.
So something's up with this clipboard app,
which I'm probably going to uninstall.
It's also super cool that when the operating system crashes,
Interessant, dass das Cinnamon zum Crashen ist.
I can still use it somehow.
On Windows, everything would go white,
and I couldn't press anything.
So let's look for another clipboard manager.
Let's try Parcelite.
Okay, installing stuff through the terminal is kind of convenient.
And, so it has an option to install itself.
Nein, das ist sein Clipboard.
Oh, that's my clipboard, I'm an idiot.
Let's see, if I click on this one, it should...
Oh, it just copies the thing I click.
Okay, and with that, we are finished.
So, how's my Linux experience?
Well, apart from some screen recording issues,
everything went pretty well. Lief doch echt gut.
Er musste sich am Anfang erstmal
ein bisschen durchbeißen mit der Grafikkarte,
aber dann war das doch easy zu benutzen für ihn.
I haven't even dipped my toes into the Linux world,
haven't even tried a bunch of the apps
like tiling window managers
or different workflows,
I just peeked my head in a little bit.
But from the basic tasks that I've done,
I can safely say that if you're not planning to record any gameplay footage,
you don't use any Adobe software
or anything else that's not available on Linux,
then for the average person
who spends most of their time on Linux,
I don't see why Linux is a bad option.
It just takes a little bit of getting used to,
just like every OS out there.
And so right now,
my favorite desktop operating system is
Oh, ich elektron-trash-torke.
Oh, jetzt war jetzt einfach fertig.
And so right now,
my favorite desktop operating system is
Ach, das war cheap-aided.
Ja, wenn du willst,
dass eine einfache Notiz-App 400 MB RAM zieht,
ist das ohne Elektron beste.
Aber manche Anwendungen wie Discord
wären ja ohne Elektron oder sagen wir mal
zumindest mit Browser,
ohne Browser-Technologie so nicht
beziehungsweise nicht in diesem
Umfang möglich gewesen.
Wenn ich mir überlege,
jemand hätte versucht Discord zu bauen
als jeweils komplette Native-Anwendung
für fünf verschiedene Plattformen,
mindestens fünf verschiedene Plattformen,
iOS,
Windows, Mac,
Linux, Android,
die wären verrückt geworden.
Vor allem hätten die Grafik,
Audio, Video-Sachen
unter
Linux
Native programmieren müssen.
Das heißt, sie hätten sich mit X und Wayland
und Puls-Audio und ALSA und Geschiss
im Leben, das wäre, das ist ja,
das ist ja eine
eine Jahrhundertaufgabe,
sowas zu entwickeln, wenn du nicht auf was zurückgreifst,
was es schon gibt.
Ja, deswegen.
Das kenne ich nicht.
Eine Custom-Discord-App.
Ja,
das liegt aber halt daran, nicht an Discord,
sondern wahrscheinlich, weil Elektron
beziehungsweise halt Chrome unter der Haube
das nicht richtig unterstützt
unter Linux.
Ich glaube, viele können sich das halt vorstellen,
dass es trotzdem, dass die auf schon
bestehende Techniken
zurückgreifen können für Discord,
unten drunter, ja,
eine enorme Herausforderung
eine Cross-Platform-Anwendung rauszubringen,
die auf allen Plattformen
funktionieren soll
und so viele Funktionen hat wie Discord.
Auch wenn du was benutzt,
also Abstraktionen unten drunter
und die halt auf die ganzen Geschichten von Chrome
zurückgreifen können, du musst trotzdem immer
kleine Workarounds für jede Plattform machen.
Also ich würde mit denen nicht tauschen wollen,
das ist bestimmt echt extremer Upfuck.
Und zumal Discord ja auch Native Node Modules
verwendet,
also irgendwelche C-Module für Node
auf Desktop-Plattformen
um manche Sachen zu beschleunigen.
Das ist schon keine
zu unterschätzende Komplexität,
die da drin steckt.
Gibt es dort ein Plugin,
dass ich alle Leute defaultmäßig muten kann
in einem Channel, außer einen?
Das ist so was,
das fehlt mir in Discord echt.
In Teamspeak ging das vor 100 Jahren schon.
Okay, Chatge.
Ich geh jetzt aufs Futter, ich hab übelst Hunger.
Wart mal kurz gucken.
Okay, Chat.
Alles klar.
Dann hören wir uns später.
Nachher wird gebastelt.
Und...
Bis dann.
CU, macht's gut.